HEARING OF THE. CALIFORNIA
SENATE ASSEMBLY JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE THIS IS THE FIFTH
CONVENE IN OF THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE SUBJECT MATTER
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE CAPITOL
BUILDING ANNEX PROJECT. AND
IT'S INTERESTING THAT PRIOR TO
THIS THE STARTED GIVING ON THIS
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE AS A
BODY HAD NOT MET. HER SIX TEEN
YEARS. SO WE ARE NOW PICKING UP
THE THREAD AGAIN OF THIS
CONVERSATION OF WHAT TO DO WITH
OUR STATE CAPITOL. THE ANNEX
PORTION WHICH WE'RE SHEER
FINISH IN NINETEEN FIFTY TWO.
AND IN AS MUCH AS WE ARE
LITERALLY YEARS AND COUNTLESS
HOURS INTO THIS EFFORT. I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T THANK ALL
THE STAFF WHO ASSISTED. US OF
COURSE JOINT RULES. SENATE
ASSEMBLY RULE SCHOLARSHIP
COUNCIL GIRL WHO IS REPRESENT
HERE OR DIE AND BORDER VINE
BUT- SHE'S PUT A LOT OF
RESOURCE IN THIS PROJECT ACROSS
MANY YEARS. OUR BUDGET
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES HAVE
DONE A GREAT DEAL OF HEAVY
LIFTING ON THIS EFFORT AS WELL
AS OF COURSE THE LEADERSHIP IN
BOTH HOUSES BOTH PARTIES. WE
HAVE GREAT PARTICIPATION AGAIN
ACROSS THE SPAN OF YEARS
DEPARTMENT PLANS TGS WAS WELL
REPRESENTED HERE TODAY. AND
EVEN OUR FACILITIES PARTNERS
BUT ALSO IN OUR COMMITTEE
STRUCTURE ARE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS HELPING
US THINK ABOUT WHAT IS THE
NARRATIVE OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE
WOULD CONVEY. WELL AS YOU
WELCOME PEOPLE IN THE BUILDING
SO WE'VE USED PRETTY MUCH EVERY
RESOURCE THE LEGISLATURE HAS.
THAT IS RELEVANT TO THE SUBJECT
HAS LENT THEIR EFFORT. AND. V.
WHEN WE GOT TOGETHER IN JULY OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE QUESTION
IS REALLY HOW DO WE TACKLE THE
DEFICIENCIES OF THE ANNEX
BUILDING FINISH IN NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO WHICH A SHORTLIST
INCLUDES ADA PROBLEMS ASBESTOS
PROBLEMS SECURITY RELATED
ISSUES AND JUST THE AGING OF
ITS SYSTEMS WHICH THAT WAS
ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED INITIALLY
UNDER GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
SDGS COMMISSION A LARGE STUDY
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX. PUTTING
TOGETHER THE IDENTIFIED
DEFICIENCIES IN THIS BUILDING.
BUT AS WE APPROACHED SEATED AS
A LEGISLATURE WE'VE NEVER LOST
TRACK OF THIS VERY UNIQUE KEY
IDEA TO THIS BILL IN STANDS
ALONE THE STATE'S INVENTORY AS
THE LEGISLATURE'S BUILDING IS
IDENTIFIED AS THE LECTURES HAVE
CALLED ON THE GOVERNMENT CODE.
AND EVERY UNDERTAKING CONCERN
AND FROM THE ORIGINAL
CONSTRUCTION THE ANNEX IN
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO THE REBUILD
OF THE WEST WING BETWEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND EIGHTY TWO AND
EVEN DEALING WITH Y. TWO K. AND
THE INTERNAL SYSTEMS OF THE
LEGISLATURE ALL THIS IS BEEN A
MEASURE BY THE LEGISLATURE ON
ITS BEHALF IN AS MUCH AS THE
BUILDING IS THE HOME OF THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE. PROCESS ARM.
AND WE'VE WE'VE ACHIEVED A LOT
SO WE NOW HAVE TWO BIG NEW
CRANES A BLOCK AWAY BEHIND ELLO
B. IS TGS IS MOVING WITH THE
UTMOST ALACRITY TO CREATE SWING
SPACE WHERE WE CAN MOVE WE ARE
JOINED TODAY ON THE AGENDA BY
MISTER DAVID HART WHO JOINED US
AT OUR JULY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
MEETING. ARE AS REALLY THE PRO
FROM DOVER HE'S WORKED ON A
GREAT MANY STATE CAPITOL RE
BILLS CARRYING THE WATER ON
BEHALF OF EXECUTIVE BRANCH IS A
LEGISLATURE SO UTAH MINNESOTA
WYOMING THESE GET INVOLVED IN
MISSOURI HIS PARTNER'S BEEN
VERY ACTIVE IN IDAHO AND WE
TALKED OVERLY ON. BUT THEN WE
WENT TO NCSL IN NCSL COMMITTED.
CONSIDER GET NO MISTER DAVID
HEART AS SOMEONE WHO MIGHT
ASSIST US. HE HAS BEEN A
CONSULTANT TO US BUT NOW WE
WERE ACTUALLY RETAINED HIM AS
THE OWNERS REPRESENT TO KINDA
HELP DRIVE THE PROJECT ALONG.
AND HE'S VERY DEEP IN THE
PROCESS OF BRINGING TO. A FINAL
FORM SOMETHING KNOWN AS THE
PROJECT JOVIAL SEQUENCING
REPORT WHICH HE WILL TALK ABOUT.
BUT STATUTES ADOPTED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE COMMITTED TO
ESTABLISHING A PROCESS THAT
WOULD IDENTIFY THE SCOPE BUDGET
DELIVER WEAPONS SCHEDULE THE
CAP LAST PROJECT THAT IS BEING
MEMORIALIZED IN THIS PROJECT
OVERVIEWS SEQUENCING DOCUMENT
WHICH MISTER HART IS A SUMMIT
FOR US AND OUR PARTNERS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND MR HERTZBERG
HERE AS MY TEAM MADE ON BEHALF
OF THE SENATE MOVING THIS ALONG.
AND SO WE'LL BE HEARING ABOUT
THAT. THERE'S SO MUCH THE WE'VE
GOT DONE IN THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS IS REALLY QUITE
REMARKABLE BUT FOR BILLS PASSED
AND SIGNED INTO LAW. DEAL WITH
VARIOUS FACETS OF THIS PROJECT
STARTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. WE
HAD A AND ANNEX WEBSITE THAT WE
GOT UP TO RUN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT'S CONTINUOUSLY
UPDATED IN FACT BEEN
SIGNIFICANT REVAMPED IN THE
LAST FEW MONTHS TO IMPROVE ITS
ADA COMPLIANCE. OUR OUR FIRST
PROCUREMENT ON THE PROJECT WAS
TO RETAIN A ARCHITECTURAL FIRM
CSE CHIU WAY OF WEST SACRAMENTO
NIGHT OWL. AND YOU MAY RECALL
LAST YEAR. TWENTY EIGHT TWO
THEY PRODUCED THIS PLANET STUDY.
AND THAT PLAN IS A REMAINS SORT
OF THE MARK OR THE BENCHMARK
FOR ONE OF THE ISSUES WITH THE
BUILDING A WHAT IS THE
CHARACTER OF A PEOPLE'S HOUSE
WE MIGHT WISH TO CONSTRUCT THAT
WAS OUR FIRST PROCUREMENT. THE
OF. WE SPENT. ABOUT THE LAST
EIGHT MONTHS OF GOVERNOR BROWN
TO TERM IN VERY SERIOUS
CONVERSATION WITH THE EXACT
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WITH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE TGS AND OUR
PARTNERS IN THE SENATE IS
SIMPLY JUST WORKING ON THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE FOR HOW WE
WOULD ADMINISTER THE PROJECT
AND THAT WAS MEMORIALIZED IN
ANIMAL YOU MEMORANDUM
UNDERSTANDING EXECUTED ON
NOVEMBER NINTH OF LAST YEAR AND
THAT COMMITTEE ERIN SERVE THEIR
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS GOVERNOR
SOME SO HERTZBERG AND I HAS
BEEN UP. MEDIAN MONTHLY SINCE
FEBRUARY AND MAKING. ESTABLISH
A I WOULD SAY A GOOD PATTERN
PRACTICE WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING.
ONE THING I WANT TO MAKE SURE I
POINT OUT FOR MY COLLEAGUES IN
THIS MEETING. YOU KNOW LET'S
SAY PROJECTS ARE SO UNUSUAL
BECAUSE THEY IMPOSE A TINY ON
US. BECAUSE WE OPERATE IN THE
TWO YEAR BIENNIUM. BUT WE'RE
ALWAYS BUSY THE FIRST THREE
MONTHS OF EVERY YEAR SO LET'S
SAY FOR. IN THE EVEN NUMBERED
YEAR WERE BUSY THAT FOURTH
QUARTER WAS ELECTIONS. SHE
REALLY LET'S SAY PROJECTS HAVE
TO BE TIME SO IF THERE IS
MOVEMENT INVOLVED OF LAWMAKER
OFFICES. YOU HAVE TO TIME IT TO
THE FOURTH QUARTER OF AN ODD
NUMBERED YEAR. BECAUSE THAT'S A
TIME WHEN WE CAN ACTUALLY
SUFFER THE DESTRUCTION. TERROR
HERE OUT FOR A COUPLE WEEKS AND
THEN SETTLE DOWN AND BE
PREPARED TO DO OUR WORK. SO A
BASIC TIMING OF THIS WHOLE
ENTERPRISE WHICH IS MOVING
ALONG AGGRESSIVELY. HAS IN MIND
THAT D. G. S. WELCOME TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE SWING SPACE
BILLION BY THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. PERMITTING THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
MOVING TO THAT NEW FACILITY IN
THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND THEN THAT THIS PROJECT
COULD BE UNDERTAKEN AND
CONCLUDED TO PERMIT US TO MOVE
BACK IN IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND IT'S SORT OF
THIS THING I DIFFER WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES TO REALIZE YOU KNOW
OUR LEGISLATIVE SCHEDULE AND
DOES IMPOSES TIME CONSTRAINT.
ARM AND THE LAST THING I JUST
WANT TO POINT ON YOU'RE GOING
TO HEAR MORE ABOUT THIS FROM
MISTER HART TODAY. SINCE EARLY
IN THIS YEAR WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY VERY HARD WITH THE STATE'S
LEADERSHIP ON. THE VISITOR
CENTER. HOW DO WE ROLL OUT THE
WELCOME MAT TO CALIFORNIA'S
WHEN THEY COME HERE OR OTHERS
FROM AROUND THE GLOBE WERE JUST
INTERESTED IN A PHENOMENON OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THE FIRST PART CHIEF
JUSTICE. ARE SENATE ASSEMBLY
LEADERSHIP ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS. AND WE CONVENE DATE A
EARLY ENVISIONED WORKSHOP AT
THE END OF APRIL THIS YEAR. AND
ALL OF USE YOU CAME BACK FROM
BREAK. WOULD HAVE FOUND COPIES
OF THIS PICTURE BOOK IN YOUR IN
BOX WHICH IS THE- ACCOUNT OF
WHAT WENT ON IN THAT EARLY
ENVISIONS SESSION. SO THINGS
ARE MOVING ALONG WITH THE
UTMOST SPEED AND. I JUST
DELIGHTED TO BE BACK AGAIN AS
WE UNDERTAKE THIS IMPORTANT
PUBLIC WORK. AND I WOULD LIKE
TO TURN AT THIS TIME OF I MADE
TO MY VICE CHAIR OF CENTER
MONEY FOR SOME REMARKS. YEAH
THANK YOU CHAIR COOLEY IN I
JUST WANT TO LEAD OFF
EXPRESSING MY APPRECIATION FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP EVEN BRACED
THIS PROJECT IN ITS MULTI
FACETED WITH A PASSION YOUR
COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIAN AS
YOU MENTION THIS IS. THIS IS
THE HOUSE OF THE LEGISLATURE
IT'S ALSO A PUBLIC HOUSE IF I'M
CORRECT WE'VE HEARD RECEIVED
MORE VISITORS EVERY YEAR THAN
DISNEYLAND. SO WHEN PEOPLE SAY
WE'RE BUILDING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THAT IS CORRECT TO
DO THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS WE'RE
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
SECURE. EIGHTY EIGHT COMPLIANT
SAFE SPACE FOR THOSE MILLIONS
OF VISITORS WHO COME THROUGH ON
EVERY YEAR THE CHAIR ALSO
MENTIONED WHEN YOU OF KNOWLEDGE
MEANING I'M NOT GOING TO REPEAT
THE NAMES IN THE TITLES BUT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
STAFF THAT HAVE PULLED TOGETHER
FROM DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO
CONSULTANTS. TO OUR LEDGE
COUNCIL EVERYONE OUR SECURITY
LEADERS IN BOTH HOUSES. THIS IS
A MAMMOTH UNDERTAKING I THINK
ONE THING THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IN MIND IS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED THIS THE VERY STRICT
TIMETABLES FOR. CONSTRUCTING
THE SWING SPACE MOVING INTO IT
GETTING ESTABLISHED AND THEN A
QUICK MOVE BACK TO THE NEW
SPACE TIMING IS EVERYTHING AND
I THINK IT'S CRITICAL WE
REMEMBER THAT THE SWING SPACE
WE WANT TO BE ACCESSIBLE SAFE
ANA IN UTILITARIAN BUT IT IS
TEMPORARY IN SWING SPACE AND WE
NEED TO DOWHAT IS NECESSARY TO
MAKE. THE SWING HAPPEN
ACCORDING TO TIME TABLE. IN
MAKE SURE THAT WE STAY ON
TARGET FOR CONSTRUCTION OF THE
NEW THE NEW ANNEX BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING THE UPDATES
TODAY I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR HERTZBERG HAS ALSO.
BEEN WITH HIS EXPERIENCES OF
FORMER SPEAKER IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND ALSO HAVING OVERSIGHT OF
BUILDING ISSUES IN. PEOPLE
MOVEMENT MANAGEMENT ISSUES HILL
OFFER HIS THOUGHTS AND OVER
SITES AS WELL BUT- THIS IS ONE
PROJECT THAT WILL HAVE A LEGACY
THAT WILL OUTLAST ALL OF THIS.
AND IT'S ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
COMPOSITION OF JOINT RULES.
WHERE WE CAN REALLY PULL
TOGETHER IN A BIPARTISAN MANNER
SHARING COMMON OBJECTIVES OF
BUILDING THAT NEXT SAFE SECURE
ADA COMPLIANT. SPACE THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO DO THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS IN THE MOST EFFICIENT
MANNER POSSIBLE SO AGAIN.
THANKS TO EVERYBODY WHO'S HERE
TODAY IN BEYOND THE WALLS OF
THE HEARING ROOM TODAY TO ALL
THOSE WHO WILL BE PARTNERS AS
WE MOVE THIS VISION FORWARD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND ALSO THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH. IT'S JUST A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONS OBVIOUSLY MISTER
ALVAREZ WHO WAS OUR FORMER
SECRETARY AND ERICA CONTRAST
OUT INSTRUMENTS IS WORKING FOR
US IN THE SENATE. DEBORAH GRAY
VIRTUES AND HERE TODAY BUT
CERTAINLY JUST EXTRAORDINARY
AMOUNT OF TIME INTO THIS OF
COURSE THE UNBELIEVABLE
ATTENTION THAT THE LEDGE
COUNSEL'S OFFICE OTHERWISE
ENGAGED IN MISTER KENNY WHO'S
BEEN THE- A DEEPLY INVOLVED AT
THE- GENERAL SERVICES. THE
THING THAT I WANT. TO ADD YOU
KNOW THE STRUCTURE AS THE CHAIR
OF. KLAY NOTED AS WE HAVE AN
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE WITH ONE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE SENATE
ONE REPRESENTS FROM THE
ASSEMBLY. AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THAT MEETS REGULARLY AND
I SUSPECT IF I HAD TO PRINT OUT
EVERYTHING THAT IS COME FROM
THAT COMMITTEE OVER THE LAST
NUMBER OF. YEAH MONTHS SO IT'S
PROBABLY TEN THOUSAND PAGES OF
STUFF. THE UNDERTAKING IS
NOTHING LESS THAN EXTRAORDINARY
TO MEET THE GOALS THE DEADLINES
THE COST AND TO DEAL WITH ALL
OF THE UNDERLYING. ISSUES THE
IN THE THING I JUST WANT TO ADD
JUST QUICKLY IS THE GREAT
CHALLENGE HERE. IS DESIGNING
FOR THE FUTURE RIGHT DESIGNING
FOR THE FUTURE TO BE
IMAGINATIVE AND CREATIVE ENOUGH
TO UNDERSTAND THAT IN A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY YEARS THIS BUILDING
WILL REMAIN. THE BUILDING THAT
WAS YOU WERE TAKING DOWN THE
ANNEX BUT IN KIT BUT IN IN IN
BEING INFORMED BY THE WEST WING
OF THE OF THE CAPITAL WHICH WAS
THE FULL CAPITAL FIGURING OUT
HOW TO DESIGN THIS IN A WAY.
THAT BOTH THAT CREATES
IMAGINATION OF THINGS WE CAN
THINK ABOUT TODAY BUT THINGS WE
HAVEN'T EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT IN
EIGHTEEN NINETY SIX ONE. THE
GREATEST MINDS AT THE WORLD
FAIRS WAS ASKED WHAT TO BROUGH
WITH THEIR PREDICTIONS WERE FOR
THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS NO ONE
THOUGHT OF THE AUTOMOBILE SHE
WAS WE'RE LOOKING AT DOING
UNDERGROUND PARKING STRUCTURES
TO CREATE THOSE IN WAYS. THAT
MAYBE THE CEILINGS ARE HIGH
ENOUGH THAT THEY CAN BE
CONVERTED TO OTHER SPACE
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER
WE'RE GOING TO BE USING
AUTOMOBILES OR NOT TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE NECESSARY SECURITY
AND PRIVACY IN OFFICES BUT THE
FLEXIBILITY TO MOVE WALLS IN
SPACES. TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
THIS LARGER COMPLEX OF NOT JUST
THE BUILDING BUT THE LARGER
CAPITAL COMMUNITY. WHEN I WAS
SPEAKER CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
WHEN WE DID HAVE HEARINGS IN
THIS COMMITTEE. WE HAD WE
BOUGHT FROM GOV THEN GOVERNOR
WHEELS TWO BUILDINGS IN THE IT
WAS A DOLLAR APIECE ONE IS THE
CURRENTLY THAT TEN TWENTY N.
STREET ONE. ONE IS THE BUILDING
THAT WAS BEHIND IT THAT HAD A
BREAK. THAT WAS TORN DOWN. AND
THE MADE FOR PARKING SPACES
BECAUSE WE NEED MORE PARKING
FOR AT THE BEFORE FOR STAFF AND
THAT NOW BECOMES LOCATION. OF
THE SWING SPACE WATER WATER ALL
THE UNDERLYING DYNAMICS OF THE
RELATIONSHIP NOW WE HAVE A
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE BUILDING
THAT HAS A LOT OF COMMITTEE
ROOMS WHAT SECOND LOOK LIKE
GOING FORWARD. SWING SPACE WILL
BE CONVERTED BACK IS. KID ACTOR
GENERAL SERVICES. BUT WHAT WILL
THERE BE A RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THOSE OFFICES OR ONE THAT'S
NEEDED. AND SO THE GREAT ISSUE
IN TERMS OF TIMING AND ALL THE
HARD WORK BUT IT'S REALLY KIND
OF THE FUN STUFF. TO TRY TO
THINK THROUGH. BUT WHAT THE
FUTURE'S GOING TO BE LIKE AND
TO GIVE HIS GREATEST AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY. FOR FIGURING OUT
ON THE FUTURE FOR REALLY MAKING
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND DEALING
WITH ALL OF THOSE ISSUES SO IT
IS BEEN QUITE CHALLENGING.
WHITE REWARDING QUITE TIME
CONSUMING BUT THE RIGHT THING
TO DO AND HOPEFULLY WE WILL
OVER THESE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS
THE BODY OF OUR WORK WILL
INFORM FUTURE GENERATIONS THAT
WILL BE HAPPY. ABOUT THE
THOUGHTFULNESS AND CREATIVITY
AND HARD WORK THAT SO MANY PUT
INTO TO HELP BUILD THE FUTURE.
OF THIS GREAT CAPITAL IN THIS
GREAT STATE. IF I MAY JUMP IN.
I DO I APPRECIATE CENTERS FURS
ALLUSION TO CREATIVITY. AND I
WANT TO SAY TO ALL THE MEMBERS
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE THAT.
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR ABOUT A
LOT OF WORK PRODUCTS THAT ARE
BEING PULLED TOGETHER
ENVISIONED GUIDELINES. REALLY
CREATIVITY IS TO WATCH FOR THIS
PROJECT IN WHICH WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. IN THE
SENATE THE MEMBERS THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF CREATIVE
THIS FLOWING. AND NOTHING
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR PREAMPS
FURTHER CREATIVITY. SO I
DEFINITELY TODAY IS INFORMATION
HEREIN BUT IT'S INVITATION JUST
BE THINKING ABOUT WHAT WE NEED
IN THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE. OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT PARTICIPATING
DEMOCRACY PARTICIPATORY
DEMOCRACY MAYBE ON THE FACE OF
THE PLANET. WHAT OTHER THINGS
WHICH ARE APT FOR ITS PURPOSE.
AND I DEFINITELY WANT TO INVITE
PEOPLE FEEL THAT THE- THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CREATIVE
IDEAS TO GET INTO. THIS
CONVERSATION AND THE SHAPE
WHERE WE GO ARE. ABUNDANT
THERE'S NOTHING THAT IS SO TIED
DOWN THAT WE CAN'T. REALLY
ALTER ADULT TIME FRAMES BECOME
AN ISSUE. WE HAVE OUR SECURITY
PARTNERS HERE TODAY BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN TALKING THEM. FOR TWO
YEARS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THE
SOONER WE HAVE OUR SECURITY
PLANS. IN MIND THE CHEAPER THEY
ARE TO IMPLEMENT ENTER NOT
SCREAM ATTHE LAST MINUTE
TRYING TO. MEAN TEN SAFETY HERE
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE ON MY
LEFT **** WILLIS SHE IS MY-
RULES COMMITTEE SECRETARY. AND
DEBORAH GRAVER OUR CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICERS IS
INDISPOSED SHE IS AWAY ON
PERSONAL MATTER THAT CANNOT WE
CAN'T INTERFERE WITH. SO SHE
WOULD ORDINARILY BE HERE SO
NICOLE WERE I'M VERY GRATEFUL
TO HAVE YOU HERE TODAY. I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE WE'VE HAD A
GREAT PARTNERSHIP WITH THE-
WITH THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION
AS WE DO WITH THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION. AND DIRECTOR
CAME OF DG **** IN THE ROOM
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE HE'S
BEEN A CONSTANT PARTNER IN THE
WHOLE EFFORT MOVING FORWARD.
AND REALLY THE LYNCH PIN TO OUR
PROJECT IS THE SWING SPACE
WHICH IS BEING BUILT BY D. G.
S. R. BASIC STATUTORY AUTHORITY
IS THE D. G. S. WILL PURSUE.
SWING SPACE AND WE WILL PURSUE
THIS BUILDING SO THEY'RE
EXECUTING ON WHAT IS THE
PRECONDITION TO THIS PROJECT.
THE LAST THING I JUST WANT TO
SAY IS I WOULD INVITE ANYONE
HAVE QUESTIONS. TO TAKE NOTE
YOUR QUESTIONS I WANT TO ASK
TURN NOW TO DIAL BORDER VINE
FOR HER PRESENTATION. WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE A FOR AT THE
END OF THAT THE LAST FASTER
HARD TO RUN TO HIS PRESENTATION
AND THEN TAKE UP QUESTIONS AT
THE END. SO WITH THAT.
COUNSELOR IS AN HONOR TO HAVE
YOU HERE AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE WORK OF YOU AND ALL YOUR
PARTNERS. AND SO I. TURN OUT OF
THAT PHASE OF OUR AGENDA. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANKS FOR INVITING ME TO
UPDATE YOU ON THE PROGRESS THAT
YOU'VE MADE TO FILL YOUR GOAL.
IN BUILDING A NEW STATE CAPITOL
ANNEX I AM GONNA GO BACK
THROUGH SOME OF MY PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY JUST TO REFRESH OUR
MEMORIES ABOUT THE LAWS. THAT
HAVE BEEN ENACTED TO DATE. WE
START OUT WITH TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED
CHAPTER THIRTY ONE AND THE
STATURE TO TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH
ADDED THE ARTICLE. THAT BECAME
KNOWN AS THE STATE CAPITAL.
BUILDING AN X. ACTIVE TWENTY
SIXTEEN IN PARTICULAR SECTION
NINE ONE ONE TWO OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE AUTHORIZES THIS
COMMITTEE. TO PURSUE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A STATE CAPITOL
ANNEX OR THE RESTORATION
REHABILITATION RENOVATION OR
RECONSTRUCTION OF THE EXISTING
STATE CAPITOL BUILDING ANNEX.
WELL THE LAW USES THAT TERM
CONTINUALLY I THINK THE
DECISION HAS BEEN MADE TO
CONSTRUCT A NEW CAPITOL ANNEX.
THEREAFTER CHAPTER THIRTY ONE
OF THE STATUES OF TWENTY
SIXTEEN AT AN ARTICLE THAT
RELATED GENERALLY TO STATE
PROJECTS BUT EXEMPTED THE WORK
TO BE DONE ON THE STATE
CAPITOL. FROM THE DEFINITION OF
THOSE PROJECTS HOWEVER OF
IMPORTANCE IT THERE IS A
SECTION THAT CREATES SOMETHING
CALLED THE STATE PROJECT
INFRASTRUCTURE FUND AS A
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED FUND
WHICH PROVIDES FOR A TRANSFER
FROM THAT FUND TO THE OPERATING
FUNDS OF THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE. THE ABOUT TO BE USE FOR
THE PROJECTS SPECIFIED IN NINE
ONE ONE TWO OF THE GOVERNMENT
CODE. THE TRANSFER OCCURS UPON
THE DIRECTION THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE AND THAT PARTICULAR
CHAPTER THIRTY ONE AT THE TIME
TRANSFERRED ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS TO THE STATE
PROJECT INFRASTRUCTURE FUND. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AB TWO SIX SIX
SEVEN WAS SIGNED INTO LAW AND
THAT BILL REQUIRES THAT ANY
WORK UNDERTAKEN IN THE ANNEX DO
THREE THINGS. FIRST IT
INCORPORATES ELEMENTS
COMPLIMENTARY TO THE HISTORIC
STATE CAPITOL ELEMENTS TO MAKE
THE STATE CAPITOL BUILDING AT
NICK'S EFFICIENT AND
SUSTAINABLE AND HISTORIC
ELEMENTS FROM THE EXISTING
STATE CAPITOL BUILDING ANNEX.
SECONDLY IT INTEGRATE DESIGN
ELEMENTS IT EDUCATE AND IMPRESS
UPON VISITORS THE RICH HERITAGE
OF SYMBOLISM OF THIS HISTORIC
STATE CAPITOL DESIGN. AND
FINALLY INCORPORATE SYMBOLIC
TREASURES. NO WE CAN TO THE
TRAILER BILL THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY HAS
REFERRED TO I'M AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SIX WAS ENACTED AS A
TRAILER BILL IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
IT AMENDED THE STATE CAPITOL
BUILDING AN EXACT TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO EXPAND THE
AUTHORITY. TO INCLUDE A VISITOR
CENTER AND AN EXPANDED AND
RELOCATED UNDERGROUND PARKING
FACILITY. THAT LEGISLATION
AMONG OTHER THINGS PROVIDED FOR
THE NEGOTIATION OF AGREEMENT AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THIS
COMMITTEE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES WITH RESPECT
TO THE STATE CAPITOL ANNEX
PROJECT. THE LEGISLATION
AUTHORIZES IS TRANSFER OF MONEY
TO FUND THE PROJECT AFTER THE
EXECUTION OF THE AGREEMENT AND
RECOGNITION OF THE PROJECT
SCOPE. BUDGET DELIVERY METHOD
AND SCHEDULE BY THE STATE
PUBLIC WORKS FOR. LEGISLATION
ALSO ALSO AUTHORIZE THE
ISSUANCE OF LEASE REVENUE BONDS
BUT THOSE LEASE REVENUE BONDS
WERE VIEWED AS A BACK UP FOR
FUNDING THE PROJECT. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE PROVIDED
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE NEW
STATE OFFICE BUILDING WHICH WE
REFER TO AS THE SWING SPACE
WHICH AS WE'VE MENTIONED WILL
BE USED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR DURING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE STATE
CAPITOL ANNEX THE BILL
APPROPRIATED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO COVER THE COST OF
THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
COMPONENTS OF THE PROJECT THAT
WILL MODIFY PORTIONS OF THE
WEST WING OF THE STATE CAPITOL
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE A FULLY
FUNCTIONAL STATE CAPITOL THE
APPROPRIATION WAS IN ACCORDANCE
WITH SECTION TWENTY EIGHT OF
ARTICLE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION WHICH RELATES TO
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE
ALTERATION OR MODIFICATION OF
ASPECTS OF THE HISTORICAL
RESTORED. AREAS THE FIRST
SECOND AND THIRD FLOORS OF THE
WEST WING OF THE CAPITOL. IN
THE BUDGET ACTED TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS WAS ADDED TO
THE STATE PROJECT
INFRASTRUCTURE FUND. SO AFTER
MANY MONTHS I THINK ABOUT EIGHT
MONTHS OF NEGOTIATION.
AGREEMENT CONTEMPLATED UNDER
THAT TRAILER BILL BETWEEN THE
COMMITTEE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE DIRECTOR
GENERAL'S DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES WAS EXECUTED. ON
NOVEMBER NINTH OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THE AGREEMENT WAS
DESIGNATED A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING AND WE COMMONLY
CALL AT THE AMMO YOU. IT
DELINEATES THE JURISDICTION OF
THE COMMITTEE OF THE STATE
CAPITOL ANNEX PROJECT AND THAT
THE JURISDICTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
OVER THE STATE OFFICE BUILDING.
IT DOES CONTEMPLATE A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS AMONGST
THE PARTIES PARTICULARLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE LEGISLATURE
SPACE IN THE STATE OFFICE
BUILDING. AND THE GOVERNOR IN
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH SPACE IN
THE NEW STATE CAPITOL ANTICS
ANNEX. UNDER THE MO YOU THE
COMMITTEE IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES IS TO PREPARE A
PROJECT. OVERVIEW AND SEE THREE
PORT WHICH WE CALL THE POS
REPORT. WHAT'S THAT REPORT IS
APPROVED BY ALL THE PARTIES TO
THE ANIMAL YOU. YEAH BUT YOU
WILL BE AMENDED TO INCORPORATE
THE POS REPORT. AND AFTER THE
REPORT IS AMENDED INTO THE MO
YOU THE STATE PUBLIC WORKS
BOARD MUST RECOGNIZE THE SCOPE
BUDGET DELIVERY METHOD AND
SCHEDULE FOR THE ANNEX PROJECT.
THEREAFTER THE FULL AMOUNT OF
THE FUNDING. PROVIDED. IN THE
TRAILER BILL WILL BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THERE ARE YOU ALSO SET FORTH A
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE WHICH HAS
BEEN ALLUDED TO IT ESTABLISHES
THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE WHICH
HAS THREE VOTING MEMBERS THOSE
MEMBERS OF THE CHAIR OF THE J.
RC. ON THE SENATE
REPRESENTATIVE WHO SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND THE GOVERNOR'S
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS THERE
ARE TWO NON VOTING MEMBERS THE
DIRECTOR GENERAL SERVICES. AND
ENTERS REPRESENTATIVE WHO IS
MISTER HART AND MOCHA. THAT
COMMITTEE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE MAJOR DECISIONS FOR THE
STATE CAPITOL ANNEX PROJECT
INCLUDING ANY CHANGES IN SCOPE.
IT MEETS MONTHLY AND IS SUBJECT
TO MAJORITY VOTE THRESHOLD.
YEAH WELL YOU HAS ANOTHER
COMMITTEE WHICH IS THE
AUTHORIZED REPRESENTATIVES
DESIGNATED TO REPRESENT EACH
HOUSE AND THEN THERE ARE TWO
NON VOTING MEMBERS THE OTHERS
REPRESENTATIVE AND A
REPRESENTATIVE SELECTED BY THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH. THE
AUTHORIZED REPRESENTATIVES WILL
MAKE THE DAY TO DAY DECISIONS
ON THE PROJECT TO DO NOT AMOUNT
TO A CHANGE IN THE SCOPE OF THE
PROJECT. THEY HAVE BEEN MEETING
REGULARLY SINCE THEY WERE
FORMED. BOTH THE STATE OFFICE
BUILDING AT THE STATE CAPITOL
AND EXPOSURE TO WELL UNDER WAY
MISTER HEARTS GOING TO DESCRIBE
THOSE THE PROGRESS SHORT
SHORTLY. WE DO HAVE ACTIVE
PROCUREMENT ON THE PROJECT
AFTER MEETING WITH VARIOUS LAW
FIRMS THE OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL HIRED NOT THAN OSMAN
LAW FIRM TO ASSIST WITH ALL THE
PROCUREMENTS. THEIR OUTSIDE
COUNSEL BRINGS TO THEPROJECT
AND EXPERTISE IN CONSTRUCTION
LAW. MISTER HART WILL DESCRIBE
THE SPECIFIC PROCUREMENTS BUT I
WANT TO ALERT THE COMMITTEE
THAT ANY PROCUREMENT DOCUMENT
THAT WE PREPARE WILL PROHIBIT
PROPOSERS FROM HAVING EX PARTE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH ANY OF YOU.
SO I'D ASK YOU TO REFRAIN FROM
SPEAKING ABOUT THE PROJECT WITH
CONTRACTS CONTRACTORS
ARCHITECTS ENGINEERS AND
LOBBYISTS WHO REPRESENT THOSE
GROUPS TO DATE THE SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS RELATED TO THE
PROCUREMENT FOR THE CAPITOL
VISITOR WELCOME CENTER. OUR
PLANT CONSTRUCTION CORPORATION
AND I'M GOING TO NOT GET THIS
NAME PROPERLY BEFORE YOU BUT
MARK. HAVE AG NARROW ASSOCIATES
AND C. S. H. Q. A. AS THE
ARCHITECTURAL FIRMS TURNER
CONSTRUCTION WITH H. G. A. AS
THE ARCHITECTURAL FIRM AND
HENSEL PHELPS WITH DREYFUS
BLACKFORD IN H. OKAY AS THE
ARCHITECTURAL FIRMS. WILL
CONTINUE TO UPDATE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH EACH REQUIREMENT
INFORMATION WITH PROCUREMENT
INFORMATION FOR PURPOSES OF THE
PROHIBITION SO YOU KNOW WHO YOU
SHOULD AND SHOULDN'T TALK TO
ABOUT THE PROJECT. IT'S BEEN MY
PRIVILEGE TO WORK ON THE
PROJECT I'M. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS BEFORE TURNING IT
OVER TO MR HARD. ANY QUESTIONS
FOR. HARLEM SHAKE. I DO WANT TO
SAY THE OUTSIDE FROM THE
NORSEMAN FIRM OF THESE ERRORS
PRECIOUS OUT OF LA THEY HAVE A
CONSTRUCTION LAW PRACTICE
THEY'VE BEEN VERY INDISPENSABLE
HELPLESS SO WITH STRICT
TURNAROUNDS AND WHAT YOU ALWAYS
WANTED YOUR LAWYERS VERY
FEARLESS TO TELL YOU WHAT THEY
THINK AND IF THEY SEE SOMETHING
I THINK IS AN ISSUE. OR NOT
BASHFUL ABOUT SERVICING IT. SO
WE CAN FIGURE OUT WHERE TO GO
THIS GETS INTO DRAFTING AND-
YOU KNOW. I HAVE FOUND THEM
VERY VERY VALUABLE ON OUR
BEHALF I'VE ALWAYS FELT. THIS
IS A PROJECT WILL CONDUCTED IN
PUBLIC FISH BOWL WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO DO IT. IN A RESPONSIBLE
MANNER AT EVERY TURN AND TO
AVOID FALL IN AND IN A MANNER
DISREPUTE. AND SO I THINK THE
NOT SPENT FIRMS DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB TO ASSIST US SO
I'M FOR A PREVIEW OF THEIR-
ROLE. OUR ANY ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTION OR ANY QUESTIONS FOR
OUR LIVES HAVE COUNSEL. ALL
RIGHT THEN AT THAT TIME I WILL
ASK MISTER DAVID HEART HE IS
WITH THE SALT LAKE CITY. UTAH
BASED FIRM KNOWN AS MOCHA. BUT
IN THIS VERY SPECIALIZED NECK
NATURE OF ASSISTING. STATE
GOVERNMENTS AROUND OUR COUNTRY
DEAL WITH AGING BUILDINGS AND
AS I SAY WE WENT. WE WENT TO A
PROCESS WHERE HE APPEARED. TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF A STATE
CAPITOL REBUILD PROCESS BACK IN
JULY OF TWENTY SIXTEEN. WITHIN
ACTUALLY FELT. PLEASE WITH THE
FOUR WORK WE SAW THERE WE
RETAIN GET FOR SOME ASSISTANCE
IN SOME OF OUR EARLY PROCESS
THEN AND SO TO ACTUALLY DECIDE
RICK RECRUITED TO BE OUR OWNERS
REPRESENT WAS SORT OF THE THIRD.
STEP IN OUR RELATIONSHIP MISTER
HART SO MR HARD IF YOU WILL
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MR VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE TODAY TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE MADE WITH REGARDS TO
THE REBUILD OF THE ANNEX AND
THE VISITOR CENTER AND- ALL THE
ASPECTS OF THE PROJECT. FIRST
OF ALL WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS
KIND OF WALK THROUGH A AN
AGENDA OF THE THINGS THAT I'LL
BE COVERING THE FIRST THING I'M
GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
IS THE OVERVIEW OF THE ANNEX
PROJECTS. YOU CAN SEE ON THE
SLIDE THAT THE VISITOR CENTER
GOAL IS TO HAVE IT COMPLETE BY
THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE PARKING STRUCTURE AND THE
ANNEX REPLACEMENT WE'RE
PLANNING TO HAVE DONE BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WE WILL THEN TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE VISITOR
CENTER WORKSHOP THAT WE'VE HELD
RECENTLY. WE'LL TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE UPCOMING PROCUREMENTS
THAT YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT WILL GO INTO A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL ON THOSE
WE'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE SWING SPACE. AND THEN TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE-
DISTRIBUTION OF INFORMATION
MISTER COOLEY STAFF ALONG WITH
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WORKING
WITHIN THE STATE AND ON OUR OUR
TEAM HAVE PUT TOGETHER SOME
VERY GOOD SOCIAL MEDIA
INFORMATION AND- IT'S VERY
IMPRESSIVE WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT AND WE'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
ANNEX. AS MENTIONED WE HAVE
BEEN PUTTING TOGETHER A PROJECT
OVERVIEW IN SEQUENCE REPORT IN
THIS DOCUMENT IT LAYS OUT AND
ORGANIZES THE APPROACH AND THE
SEQUENCE TO HOW THE WORK IS
GOING TO BE DONE. OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS WE GO YEAR BY
YEAR AND TALK ABOUT DIFFERENT
ASPECTS WITHIN THAT REPORT WE
POINT OUT THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS AND ELEMENTS OF THE
PROJECT SO THE AREA THAT YOU
SEE HERE AND PINK. IS THE
LOCATION THAT WE ARE PLANNING
TO PUT THE VISITOR CENTER THE
VISITORS CENTER WILL BE BELOW
GRADE WHEN YOU STAND ON THE
MALL AND YOU LOOK BACK AT THE
CAPITOL YOU WON'T SEE ANY OF
IT. WE WANT TO PRESERVE THE
VIEW WE WANT TO PRESERVE THE
TREES AND DO WHAT WE CAN TO HI
THE FACILITY YET STILL ALLOW
FOR THE FACILITY TO BE A
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL PEOPLE TO
COME TO THE CAPITAL AND
EXPERIENCE THE IMPORTANCE OF
BOTH CALIFORNIA AND THE WORK.
THAT IS DONE HERE. THE ANNEX.
OF COURSE WILL BE REMOVED AND
THEN REPLACED. WE SEE THAT
SITTING APPROXIMATELY IN THE
LOCATION IDENTIFIED BY THE BLUE
SQUARE. AND THEN A PARKING
STRUCTURE IS MISTER HERTZBERG
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS INDICATED
WILL BE LOCATED TO THE- SOUTH.
WE ARE LOOKING AT CURRENTLY TO
SCHEMES FOR THE PARKING
STRUCTURE ONE IS A TWO LEVEL
BELOW GRADE PARKING STRUCTURE.
THAT WOULD BE MORE OR LESS A
TYPICAL PARKING FACILITY AND
THE OTHER ONE IS THE ONE THAT.
HE ALLUDED TO WHICH MIGHT BE A
HIGHER FLOOR. ONLY ONE LEVEL
BELOW GRADE AND MAY ALLOW FOR
FUTURE FLEXIBILITY IN THAT WE
MAY SEE A REDUCTION AND
AUTOMOBILES ARE CHANGING
PERSONAL TRANSPORTATION. THESE
THREE PROJECTS REALLY COMPRISE
THE OVERALL PROJECT THAT WE
REFER TO AS THE ANNEX PROJECTS.
IN ADDITION TO THE SEQUENCE
REPORT THAT WE HAVE PUT
TOGETHER WE HAVE ALSO PUT
TOGETHER SET OF DESIGN
GUIDELINES FOR THE VISITOR
CENTER WITHIN THOSE GUIDELINES
THESE ARE HIGH ASPIRATIONAL
GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN TALKED
ABOUT BY BOTH THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE IN THE AUTHORIZED
REPRESENTATIVES AND OTHERS. THE
TALK ABOUT THE THINGS THAT ARE
VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO INCLUDE
WITHIN THE PROJECT SOME OF
THESE THINGS HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED TODAY BY SENATOR
MORNING WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT
EIGHTY A SECURITY MAKING SURE
IT'S WELCOME OF THE PEOPLE CAN
COME IN THOSE ARE THE TYPE OF
ELEMENTS. WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
SOME GUIDING PRINCIPLES THAT WE.
ARE HOLDING UP VERY HIGH AND
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ACCOMPLISH FIRST IS INCLUSIVE
AND WELCOMING FOR THE VISITOR
CENTER. WE ALSO WANT TO BE ABLE
TO BRING PEOPLE AND MAKE THEM
FEEL LIKE THIS IS PART OF
THEIRS. WE HAD A CONVERSATION
WHILE WE WERE GOING THROUGH
THIS AND SOMEBODY MENTIONED I
CAN'T REMEMBER WHO IT WAS THAT.
THEY KNEW SOMEBODY WHO FELT.
LIKE THEY COULDN'T COME IN TO
THE BUILDING. AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY EVERYBODY
FEELS LIKE THEY CAN COME IN
REGARDLESS OF WHO THEY ARE OR
WHAT CONDITION THERE IN THAT
THE BUILDING IS WELCOMING IT
BRINGS THEM AND GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. VISIT WITH
MEMBERS AND TO BE INVOLVED IN
THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS.
FUNCTIONAL WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE VISITOR CENTER IS ALSO
FUNCTIONALLY RECOGNIZE IT IS
GOING TO BE THE FRONT DOOR OF
THE BUILDING. FOR THE NEXT THE
FIVE YEARS UNTIL THE ANNEXES
REPLACED WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO COME IN
AND MOVE QUICKLY THROUGH IT IF
THEY WANT TO GO THROUGH THE
EXHIBITS AND THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO THROUGH THOSE
BUT IF THEY NEED TO MOVE INTO
THE CAPITAL. TO COME UP AND
VISIT WITH ONE OF YOU OR TO
PARTICIPATE IN A HEARING. WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND
THEN SAFE SECURE ACCESS. DAYS
TODAY WHERE WE'RE SEEING A LOT
OF DIFFERENT ISSUES ARISE. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE AS THEY COME INTO THE
BUILDING NOT ONLY FILL. WELCOME
AND INCLUDED BUT THAT THEY'RE
SAFE AND THAT THEY'RE
COMFORTABLE. AND THAT THEY CAN
TAKE TIME AND RELAX AND THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT. SO MISTER COOLEY
MENTION THAT WE HAD RECENTLY
HELD A- VISITOR CENTER
WORKSHOP. WE PULL TOGETHER
SEVERAL. INDIVIDUALS FROM BOTH
WITHIN STATE GOVERNMENT. THERE
WERE SEVERAL PEOPLE THAT MISTER
COOLIES OFFICE INVITED TO COME
IN THAT WERE EDUCATORS. AND
ALIKE AS WELL AS CONSULTANTS.
AND WE ASSEMBLED A GROUP OF
PEOLE WE TALKED ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT NEEDED TO OCCUR
WITHIN THE VISITOR CENTER. AND
OUT OF THAT CAME THIS BLUE BOOK
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE SEEN THAT
HAS BEEN. HANDED OUT TO EACH
ONE OF YOU. AND IT GOES THROUGH
AND IT GIVES A VERY GOOD
DETAILED DISCUSSION. OF WHAT
ELEMENTS SHOULD BE INCORPORATED
IN SHOULD BE INCLUDED WITHIN
THE- VISITOR CENTER. THE OTHER
THING THAT IS IMPORTANT ABOUT
THAT IS THAT WE HAVE NOW
PROVIDED THAT BOOK TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE.
PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROCUREMENTS. SO THEY HAVE AN
IDEA OF WHAT IT IS THE- BODY IS
LOOKING FOR AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT AS WE'RE GOING
THROUGH A SELECTION PROCESS.
WITHIN THAT WE IDENTIFIED A
FLOW AND CIRCULATION THAT
SHOULD TAKE PLACE WITHIN THE
VISITOR CENTER FROM THE TIME
THEY COME INTO THE BUILDING. TO
HOW THEY MOVE THROUGH THE SPACE
HOW THEY GO THROUGH SECURITY
HOW THEY MOVE INTO THE EXHIBIT
AREAS AND HOW THEY MOVE FROM
THE EXHIBIT AREAS. EITHER INTO
A SPECIALIZED ROOM OR SOME TYPE
OF TRAINING FACILITY. AND ON UP
INTO THE CAPITAL PROPER ITSELF
AND THEN INTO THE REST OF THE
FACILITY. WE HAVE THEN TRIED TO
DIAGRAM THAT IN A GRAPHIC
FORMAT THAT YOU CAN SEE ON THE
RIGHT HAND SIDE WHERE AS AS
PEOPLE COME INTO THE WELCOMING.
AND ASSEMBLY AREA THEY WOULD
ASSEMBLE THERE AND THEN MOVE
INTO THE VISITOR AND WELCOME
CENTER. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO REALLY TRY TO
ACCOMPLISH IS TO GIVE PEOPLE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO Q. PRIOR TO
GOING THROUGH SECURITY IN A DRY
COMFORTABLE SPACE. WHERE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
CAN BE PROVIDED TO THEM RATHER
THAN HAVING THEM STAND OUTSIDE
IN THE RAIN. WITH UMBRELLAS
WAITING TO GET IN TO THE
BUILDING. IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THE PROCESS
BY WHICH WE BELIEVE. THE
EXHIBIT DESIGNERS WILL MOVE
THROUGH AND IT IS BEEN ALIGNED
WITH THE DESIGN PROCESS THAT
THE PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILDERS
WILL USE. AS THEY PUT TOGETHER
THE BUILDING AND SO WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT. IN THE PROJECT
DEFINITION WHICH IS USUALLY THE
FIRST PHASE THAT THE DESIGNERS
WILL GO THROUGH. THEY WILL BE
LOOKING AT WHAT IS THE AUDIENCE
AND HOW ARE WE GOING TO FOCUS.
THE VISITOR CENTER ON THE
AUDIENCE AND WHAT ARE THE WHAT
ARE THE MESSAGES WE WANT TO
SEND. SCHEMATIC DESIGN THE
VISITOR CENTER WILL FOCUS ON
THEMING AND STORY LINE. WITHIN
THE DESIGN DEVELOPMENT OF THE
PROJECT THEY WILL LOOK AT THE
PRESENTATIONSAND HOW THOSE
WILL BE INCORPORATED. ALSO AT
THIS POINT WE WILL WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE PROGRESSIVE
DIVIDE DESIGN BUILD TEAMS. TO
DETERMINE WHAT PORTIONS OF THE
EXHIBIT FURNITURE OR THE
EXHIBIT CABINET TREE. WILL BE
BECOME PART OF THE DESIGN BUILD
OR WILL BECOME PART OF THE-
PROCUREMENT FOR EXHIBIT
MATERIALS. THE REASON THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS THAT IT'S ALWAYS
LESS EXPENSIVE TO HAVE A
CONTRACTOR PROVIDE THOSE RATHER
THAN GO OUT. AND DO A SEPARATE
PROCUREMENT SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
WAYS WE CAN. SAVE MONEY AND
STILL PROVIDE A VERY HIGH
CAPITAL QUALITY. XIN ASPECTS OF
THE EXHIBIT. AS MENTIONED WE
ARE IN A PERIOD OF ACTIVE
PROCUREMENT. PRESENTLY WITH THE
EXHIBIT DESIGNERS WE HAVE.
RECEIVED A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS
WE ARE GOING THROUGH THOSE
PROPOSALS. AND WILL BE A SHORT
LISTING THOSE WE ANTICIPATE
NEXT WEEK IN THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE. IN REGARDS TO THE
PROCUREMENTS AS WAS MENTIONED
WE HAVE THE VISITOR CENTER
PROCUREMENT FOR THE TO
PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILD TEAMS
WE HAVE SHORTLISTED THE TEAMS
AS OF JULY THIRTY FIRST WE WILL
DO THE SELECTION. ON SEPTEMBER
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO ANNOUNCE
THE SELECTION ON SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH AND THEN WE ARE
LOOKING FOR THEM TO BEGIN WORK
AROUND OCTOBER ELEVENTH WE
WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT EARLIER FOR ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THE CONTRACTING. THE
PROPOSALS FOR THE EXHIBIT
DESIGNER HAVE BEEN RECEIVED WE
HAVE GONE THROUGH THOSE WE WILL
BE SHORT LISTING AND THEN GOING
THROUGH A SELECTION AND WE HOPE
TO MAKE THAT ANNOUNCEMENT AGAIN
AROUND THE SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH
AND THEN BEGAN WORK ON THE
ELEVENTH. YOU WILL NOTE THAT WE
HAVE TRIED TO ALIGN THESE TO
PROCUREMENT SO THAT BOTH THE S.
OF THIS BILL. THE DESIGNER
SELECTION WILL OCCUR AT THE
SAME TIME SO THEY CAN WORK
TOGETHER. AND THAT THEY CAN
<c.green>OLLABORATE ONE WITH ANOTHER SO</c>
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO BUILD
OFF OF ONE ANOTHER. WE ALSO
HAVE SOME UPCOMING
PROCUREMENTS. THE FIRST WILL BE
FOR THE ANNEX ARCHITECT AND
ENGINEER WE ARE PURSUING THIS
IS WHAT'S CALLED A CONSTRUCTION
MANAGER AT RISK PROGRAM. WHERE
THE OWNER WILL HOLD BOTH THE
CONTRACT FOR THE ARCHITECT AND
ENGINEER AND THEY WILL HOLD THE
CONTRACT FOR THE CONTRACTOR. WE
WILL BRING ON THE ARCHITECT
HAVE THE SHORTLIST WILL PUT OUT
THE R. F. P. SHORTLY AND HAVE
THE SHORTLIST AROUND OF THE
FOURTEENTH OF NOVEMBER.
SELECTION BY THE MIDDLE OF
JANUARY AND THEN BEGAN WORK IN
IN MARCH. LIKEWISE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT RISK WE
WILL FOLLOW A LITTLE BIT WE
WILL START TO ACTUALLY WITH THE
SHORT LIST AHEAD OF THE
ARCHITECT AROUND NOVEMBER
FOURTH. AND THEN IT'S A LITTLE
LONGER PROCESS FOR THE
CONTRACTOR WE WILL THEN HAVE
THE SELECTION BY THE END OF
JANUARY. AGAIN HOPE TO START
AROUND THE FIRST PART OF MARCH.
THE SWING SPACE HAS AS YOU CAN
SEE BY THE PICTURE WE HAD A
GROUNDBREAKING CEREMONY. AND I
THINK YOU CAN SEE THIS IS
REALLY A LOT OF IF NOT ALL OF
YOUR TEAM MEMBERS. AND THEY HAD
A LOT OF FUN ON OCTOBER
FIFTEENTH AT THE GROUND
BREAKING THE BUILDING IS MOVING
UP YOU CAN START TO SEE THAT
THERE ARE TWO CRANES UP AS
CHAIRMAN COOLEY. ALLUDED TO AND
IT'S A LOT OF FUN SEEING THAT
GOING UP AND WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
BE PARTNERING WITH D. G. S. ON
THIS PROJECT THAT THEY ARE
LEADING IN AND WE ARE PROVIDING
SOME. REVIEW OF IT SHOULD BE A
BEAUTIFUL BUILDING AS YOU CAN
SEE IN THE PHOTOGRAPHS THE
CENTER OF THE BUILDING WILL BE
OPEN AND HAVE MULTIPLE ATRIUMS.
AND SHOULD BE A VERY VERY
BEAUTIFUL BUILDING ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS IS
WE'VE DONE A RE BRANDING. OF
THE WEBSITE. YOU CAN NOW SEE
THAT THE WEBSITE IS UP AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO GO LOOK AT IT
THERE'S A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
PLACES AND THINGS THAT YOU CAN
SEE THERE FROM JUST GAINING
SOME INFORMATION AND WE'RE ALSO
USING THIS TO DISTRIBUTE. THE
INFORMATION TO THE CONTRACTORS
AND TO THE INTERESTED
ARCHITECTS. THE NEW DESIGN IS
VERY EASY TO USE AND IT I THINK
BRINGS THE- PROJECT LEVEL OF
SOPHISTICATION AND
PROFESSIONALISM THAT IT REALLY
DESERVES. IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE HAVE HAD SOME NEWS RELEASES
THAT MR COOLEY IS PUT OUT
THROUGH HIS STAFF AND THEN. HIS
STAFF IS ALSO BEEN WORKING A
LOT WITH PUTTING INFORMATION
OUT TO THE STAFF AND THE AND
THE DIFFERENT FOLKS WITHIN THE
ANNEX BUILDING PROPER SO. WE'RE
TRYING TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
COMMUNICATE THE WORK THAT IS
GOING FORWARD AND MAKING SURE
THAT EVERYBODY IS INFORMED IN.
AND UP TO. SPEED ON ON THE
PROGRESS. FINALLY WHERE WE ARE
PRESENTLY AS WE ARE PUTTING
TOGETHER THE ANNEX BUILDING
GUIDELINES THESE ARE SIMILAR TO
THE VISITOR CENTER GUIDELINES
AND THAT THEY WILL BE. AGAIN
THINGS THAT WE CARE THE MOST
ABOUT AND WE WANT TO TRANSMIT
TO THE ARCHITECTS. THEY WILL BE
COMING TOGETHER IN THOSE WILL
BE READY IN ABOUT ANOTHER MONTH
OR SO. SO THAT THE THEY CAN BE
READY TO GO WITH THE
PROCUREMENT. AS PART OF THE
WORK ON THE ANNEX WE HAVE
SPENT. A LOT OF TIME. LOOKING
AT THE WORK THAT WAS DONE
PREVIOUSLY BY THE ARCHITECTURAL
FIRM THAT DEVELOPED THE BLUE
BOOK. THEY PROVIDED US WITH
WHAT'S CALLED A SPACE PROGRAM
WHICH BASICALLY LAYS OUT THE
AMOUNT OF SQUARE FOOTAGE THAT
EACH OFFICER OR FACILITY OR
FUNCTION WITHIN THE BUILDING
WILL. WILL HAVE WE'VE GONE BACK
THROUGH THAT ANALYZE THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT A FACILITY FOR
THE ANNEX OF ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET. VISITORS CENTER IS
APPROXIMATELY FORTY THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY PARKING
STALLS. IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT DOING A BUILDING
THAT IS. SUSTAINABLE WE ARE
LOOKING AT LEAD RE USE OF
EXISTING MATERIALS THAT ARE
WITHIN THE BUILDING. AND WE
WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
WOOD THAT HAS BEEN HARVESTED OR
WHEN IT FELL. DURING A STORM WE
HAVE HOLD HELD ON TO THAT AND
SO WE HAVE USED THE WORD FROM
THE CIVIL WAR TREES. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS ABLE TO
BE USED IN. AND PRESENTED
WITHIN THE BUILDING. WE'RE
LOOKING AT NET ZERO ENERGY WE'D
LIKE TO MOVE TOWARDS A LOW
CARBON AND ELECTRIFICATION OF
BUILDINGS. INCLUDING DAYLIGHT
HARVESTING NATURAL LIGHTING
VIEWS AND WHERE WE CAN WE WOULD
LIKE TO USE GRAY WATER WE USE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BUILDING
SHOULD BE AS MR COOLEY SAYS ONE
OF THE MOST ENERGY EFFICIENT
CAPITOL. BUILDINGS IN THE
NATION AND WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS THAT GOAL. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE STUDYING AND
WILL BE WORKING ON OVER THE
NEXT LITTLE BIT IS. WHAT
FUNCTIONS WITHIN THE CURRENT
ANNEX NEED TO MOVE INTO THE
WEST WING AS WE- VACATE THE
ADDICTS AND MOVED IN TO THE
TENTH AND SWING SPACE. THAT WAY
WE CAN KEEP THE- LEGISLATURE IN
YOUR FUNCTIONS GOING WITHIN THE
WEST WING WHILE YOU ARE LIVING
IN THE TEMPORAL BUILDING. SO WE
ARE IDENTIFYING THOSE THINGS
WERE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
SPACE FOR THAT. WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SPACE OR MAKE SURE THAT
LEADERSHIP IS STILL AVAILABLE
TO DO ALL THE THINGS THAT THEY
NEED TO DO WITH IN THE WEST
WING AS WELL SO. IT'S KIND OF A
COMPLICATED. GAME OF. MOVING
PIECES AROUND BUT I THINK
THAT'S COMING TOGETHER IF I MAY
JUST JUMP IN ON THE SLIDE SO
THE- THE BOTTOM LINE IS. OUR
CHAMBERS. ARE CURRENTLY
SUPPORTED BY TURKS OFFICES
SERGEANTS OFFICES AND **** IN
SPACES. ALL OF WHICH ARE IN THE
ANNEX PORTION. OF THE BUILDING.
SO THIS CHART IS ACTUALLY
DEPICTING THIS IDEA. THAT WHILE
SPACE WILL BE RETAINED IN THE
LEADERSHIP SWEETS RIGHT OFF THE
CHAMBERS. ON THE OUTER WALL OF
THE BUILDING NORTH AND SOUTH.
CENTRAL PORTIONS WILL BE
REPURPOSE PROVIDE COXON SPACES
ON THE SAME LEVEL AS THE
CHAMBERS. SO THAT IF WE'RE IN
SESSION WE'RE GOOD IF WE NEED
TO RETREAT TO CAUCUSES OF THE
SPACE PROVIDED CONVENE IT TO
THE FLOOR. AND SO THAT'S PART
OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
HISTORIC CAPITAL REMAINS THE
WORKING CAPITAL NOT A MUSEUM
OUR SESSIONS WILL CONTINUE AND
SO I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THIS IS ACTUALLY A FAIRLY
IMPORTANT SLIDE IN TERMS OF
JUST THINKING ABOUT HOW WILL
MAKE THE BUILDING WORK. AND
THESE WERE REPRESENT. TEMPORARY
CHAMBERS BUT ON THE
CONSTITUTION THEY ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE A SEPARATE
APPROPRIATION PAY FOR THEM SO
THAT'S WHAT TIME FOR WINE WAS
REVIEWING SEEN ADDED TWENTY
MILLION APPROPRIATION UNDER
THIS PARTICULAR BILL THAT WAS
MADE IN THE CONSCIOUS FOR PRO
REQUISITES FOR TOUCHING THE
WEST WING A BROWN TEMPORARY
BASIS AND AS YOU COME TO WE'RE
GOING TO TURN A HOLLY MITCHELL
IN A MINUTE FOR THE FIRST
QUESTIONS BUT PLEASE CALL CAN
YOU I'M NOT TELLING THAT'S
GOING TO STATE SHE'S UP FIRST
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. SO MOVING ON THE THIS IS
A GRAPHIC THAT DEMONSTRATES
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS WE ARE
TRYING TO DO IS ALIGN THE
FLOORS AS YOU KNOW FOR THE LAST
SO MANY YEARS SINCE NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO IN THE BUILDING WAS
BUILT THERE WAS NO ALIGNMENT OF
THE FLOORS REALLY TO SPEAK OF
SO ONE OF THE GOALS IS TO ALIGN
THE FLOORS AND YOU CAN SEE THE
APPROXIMATE MASS THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING. AT WAYS TO REDUCE THAT
MASS. AND TRY TO STE. ALL OF
THE- ASPECTS. WE HAVE GONE
THROUGH AND TRIED TO DO A VERY
DETAILED STUDY OF THE BUDGET AS
BEST WE CAN AT THIS POINT IN
TIME TRYING TO ESTIMATOR
GUESSTIMATE. THOSE THINGS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO ACCOUNT
FOR. AND TRY TO FUND. I'M HAPPY
TO REPORT THAT WE HAVE A BUDGET
MODEL THAT IS IN BUDGET AND
WE'RE I THINK WE'RE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT. AND
THEN WITH REGARDS TO SCHEDULE
WE HAVE BUILT A SCHEDULE THAT
WE ARE USING TO GUIDE OUR
DIRECTION. WITH REGARDS TO HOW
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD AND AT
THIS POINT IN TIME WITH REGARDS
TO THAT WE ARE SITTING ON
SCHEDULE. AS WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD. AND SO WITH THAT I
WILL BE HAPPY TO. ENTERTAIN
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
HART THIS SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE IT. FIRST
OF ALL DO A VERY BRIEF
STATEMENT I'M SO EXCITED ABOUT
THE CONCERT WITH THE VISITOR
CENTER AS EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE
MEMBER TO NCSL I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY IN RECENT YEARS TO
TRAVEL TO A NUMBER OF OUR STATE
CAPITALS IN A NUMBER OF THEM
THAT HAVE DONE. HAD RESET
CERTAINLY MORE RECENT THAN OURS
CONSTRUCTION HAVE THESE VISITOR
CENTERS AND THEY'RE JUST
WONDERFUL MODELS TO SEE SO I
THINK THAT WILL BUILD VERY WELL
FOR OUR STATE NOW AS MR
HERTZBERG SAID HIS OPENING
REMARKS THAT THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGE BEFORE US TO BUILD
AND CONSTRUCTION AND CONSTRUCT
AND IMAGINE SOMETHING FOR THE
FUTURE I THINK THAT SPACE.
MAKES SENSE SINCE I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT. ON TO MY
QUESTION I'M NOT SURE. IF IT'S
MOST APPROPRIATE FOR YOU MISTER
HART OR YOU MISS PLAYER VINE.
BUT IT DEALS WITH THE ISSUE OF
PROCUREMENT. AND GIVEN THE
SITES. AND SCOPE SIZE AS IN.
THE MONETARY SIDE HACE. OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND THE
SIGNIFICANCE THE HISTORICAL
SIGNIFICANCE. I AM HOPING THAT
IN OUR PROCUREMENT PROCESS
WE'RE LOOKING AT. CALIFORNIA
BASED FIRMS. GIVEN THE FACT
THAT IT'S THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CAPITOL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AND I'M ALSO HOPING THAT
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME TARGETED
OUTREACH TO WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED FIRMS. REALLY WITH MIKE
MICHAEL BEING THAT THEY HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY HOPEFULLY THE
SERVICE PRINCIPLES AND NOT JUST
US UP. AND SO IF THERE'S BEEN
TARGET OUT REACH AND IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT CALIFORNIA BASED
FIRMS EXCLUSIVELY SO MISTER
HART CAN CONFIRM THIS BUT I
BELIEVE IN OUR- OUR OUR BIGGEST
PROCUREMENT SO FAR IS THE
CAPITOL VISITOR CENTER. THEY
BELIEVE THEY HAVE TO HAVE AN
OFFICE BASED IN CALIFORNIA WAS
THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE A THEY
MUST HAVE A CALIFORNIA LICENSE.
AND THAT THEY WILL HAVE TO HAVE
A OFFICE SPACE IN SACRAMENTO.
THE IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY
ARE CALIFORNIA FIRM STATUS WILL
THAT IS. OFFICE OKAY. THE ISSUE
OF MINORITY AND WOMEN OWNED
ENTERPRISES IS COMPLICATED.
BECAUSE JUST YOU UNDERSTAND
PROP TWO OH NINE PROHIBITS.
PROCUREMENT THAT ARE TARGETED
TOWARD THEM IT DOESN'T FOR CARE
PROHIBITS OUT OF REACH ON A
DOZEN PROHIBITS TARGETED OUT
REACH WHEN I THINK TARGETED OUT
REACH I MEAN IT EIGHT A
PROACTIVE EFFORT TO FIND AND
IDENTIFY SO WHAT WE ARE DOING
WE HAVE A COUPLE THINGS GOING
ON WORK WE'RE DEFINITELY
LOOKING AT SMALL BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES AND DISABLED THAT.
AND USING SOME OF THE FORMS
HOPEFULLY THAT WE'VE TALKED
WITH DTS BUT USING SOME OF
THEIR OUTRAGE MECHANISMS AND MY
GET HOPE WOULD BE THAT WITHIN
THOSE WE WOULD GET TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND THAT THE
OUTREACH EFFORTS THEY HAVE
MIGHT HAVE. MINORITY AND WOMEN
OWNED ENTERPRISES. SO THAT'S
THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE WOULD BE
DOING WITH RESPECT TO THOSE
THAT REJECT BIRDS. AND AGAIN I
JUST BUT I GUESS MY POINT BEING
GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS
INVESTMENT. AND THE HISTORICAL
RELEVANCE HISTORIC RELEVANCE OF
BUILDING A NEW STATE CAPITOL
BUT I HOPE THAT WE WOULD REALLY
TRY TO COMPLY WITH. THE SPIRIT
OF THE GOALS OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN TERMS OF OUR PUBLIC
INVESTMENT. AND SO IF THERE ARE
WAYS THAT WE CAN CONNECT WITH
NOVEL ONE OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
TO. BREAKING THESE
OPPORTUNITIES TO YOUR ATTENTION
I CERTAINLY WILL DO SO I YOU
KNOW I'M APPRECIATE. THE
CONFINES OF PROP TWO OH NINE
AND I THINK ULTIMATELY THAT IT
LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO
PRIORITIZE OR GIVE RIGHT
PRIORITY TO. BUT AGAIN IN TERMS
OF MY EXPECTATION AROUND ERNEST
OUT OF REACH TO WOMEN AND
MINORITY EARN. MINORITY OWNED
FIRMS I THINK IT CAN BE DONE
EVEN WITHIN THE CONFINES OF THE
LAN SO. I WOULD ENCOURAGE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND OF THE
ETHNIC CAUCUSES TO TAP INTO OUR
NETWORKS TO REALLY TRY TO HELP
FACILITATE THAT. WE CAN
ABSOLUTELY. WE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR BURGER CENTER
HERTZBERG. HE'S NOT SURE WITH
THE OTHER MEMBERS. JUST BRIEFLY
THANK YOU OF A COUPLE OF
THOUGHTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGING IN IN TRYING TO DESIGN
THIS. WHAT THE FUTURE IS SENATE
MITCHELL INCORPORATED BUT ALSO
HAVE SOME CONVENIENCES THAT
UNDERSTAND. THE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES UNIQUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE OFTEN IT TERMS OF
REDESIGNING WHEN PEOPLE LINED
UP RIGHT HOW MANY MAGNETOMETERS
ARE THERE. HOW DO WE GET PEOPLE
IN TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE TAKING
CARE OF WE HAVE BIG DAYS WHERE
WE HAVE A LOT OF BILLS WHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS THAT ARE
INTERESTED AND EXERCISING THEIR
VOICE AND WORKING WITH. OUR OWN
SECURITY FOLKS IN TRYING TO
FIGURE THAT OUT RIGHT SOME OF
THE UNIQUE NATURE OF THE THINGS
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE NOW IS WE HAVE
SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY OFFICE
COMMITTEE STAFFS. COMMITTEE
OFFICES IN THE L. O. B. AND
WE'VE GOT A NUMBER STAFF BOTH
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY MOSTLY
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE. BUT LIKE
WHAT ABOUT THE TRAFFIC BACK AND
FORTH RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT A BIG
DEAL BUT IF YOU OF THE THAT
SWING SPACE THAT NOW HAS THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH. BOOK
EVERYTHING IT'S IN THIS SITE
ALTHOUGH IT LEGISLATIVE OFFICES
ALL OVER STAFFS. IT WILL REDUCE
IT WILL REPRODUCE THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM AND THE YOUR
BACK BUDGET COMMITTEE ROOM
ACROSS. AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE
THAT MUCH MOVEMENT AT ALL OF A
SUDDEN THIS COMMITTEES AND THEN
YOU GOT TO THINK THROUGH THE
CAR JUST TO KIND ISSUE SPOT FOR
EVERYBODY. YOU GOT COMMITTEES
OVER HERE IN THE OLD PART AND
THEN YOU GOT COMMITTEES OVER
THERE IN THE NEW PARK HOW DO
YOU GET BACK AND FORTH SO
QUICKLY IN TERMS OF MEMBERS.
YOU OF ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU'VE
GOT YOU'VE GOT A CAUCUSES OR
YOU'LL HAVE SESSION THAT MOVE.
IS GOING TO BE DRAMATICALLY
MORE GREATER THAN MOVES THAT
HAVE NOW IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING THAT SO DEALING
WITH TRAFFIC WE'RE TALKING TO
THE CITY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE STREETS
OF THESE DECISIONS HAVE BEEN
MADE. BUT IT WILL THE POINT OF
TAKING A MOMENT. TO TRY. TO
SHARE WITH THE- MEMBERS OF THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE. IS THAT
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
ARE TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH. AND
REALLY GET THE DAY TO DAY
EXPERIENCES AND WHAT OUR NEEDS
ARE AND THE NEEDS OF. THE
COMMUNITY WHEN THEY COME UP AND
THEY WANT TO HAVE A VOICE IN
WHAT IS THAT LOOK LIKE. AND THE
HALLWAYS AND HOW WIDE THEY ARE
WHEN THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS
WITH THEIR LINE UP BECAUSE
THERE'S A BIG PARTICULAR ISSUE
OF WHATEVER THAT ISSUES OF THE
DAY. HOW DOES THAT STUFF WORKS
A LOT OF THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
IN ADDITION TO THE CONSTRUCTION
ISSUES AND KIND OF THE NORMAL
ISSUES. WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO.
ARE ALL IN YOUR CHECKED. INTO
THE LARGER DISCUSSION THAT HAS
THAT PRACTICAL AS ANY OF THE
THOUGHT YOU'VE GOT. IT'S HARD
TO THINK IN THROUGH ALL THIS
STUFF SO. THE JUST TO SHARE OF
SOME SOME ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
BEEN GRAPPLING WITH THIS WE'VE
BEEN GOING FORWARD ON THIS. TO
TRY TO LOOK AT THE PRACTICAL
WITH EVERYBODY FROM SECURITY
EVERY OTHER ISSUE. ON THE DAY
WERE LITERALLY COUNTING ON
THOSE BIG DAIS GERMAN COULD.
YOU TO. HEY I'M THOSE BIG BASS
THE SERGEANTS OF COUNT OF HOW
MANY PEOPLE WALK THROUGH. AND
WHAT IS THAT LOOK LIKE TO HELP
INFORM. BECAUSE THOSE ARE GOING
TO BE ISSUES THAT ARE ARE
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT AS WE-
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND IN THIS
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
STUFF WORKS AT THE BACK AND
FORTH IS GONNA BE QUITE
CHALLENGING. WE'RE GONNA JUMP
TO MISTER MOM. MONNING AND THEN
MITCHELL I WANT TO JUST SAY. ON
THIS ONE ONE ISSUE THAT YOU
RAISE WHICH IS DEFINITELY ONE.
WE HAVE DONE A LOT TO
COMMUNICATE ABOUT THE PROJECT
WE'VE HAD THE WEBSITE UP FOR
TWENTY EIGHT MONTHS
CONTINUOUSLY. MISTER MOKO OR
MISTER HART AND LOCAL ONE HIS
PRIORITIES HAS BEEN A RECENTLY
CONDUCTED INDUSTRY DAY. THAT
WAS IN THIS HERE THIS ROOM WAS
PACKED OUT THE ROOM PUBLICIZE
WHAT'S GOING ON. I AM CERTAINLY
BEEN SORT OF. A NOT ON THE
ISSUE FRANKLY TALKING THEN ONE
ONE YOU KNOW WASN'T MOVING
ABOUT THE PROJECT SO NOW IN THE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS I AM BEING
MORE RESTRAINED. ABOUT WHO I
TALKED TO JUST BECAUSE I NEVER
WANT TO BRING DISCREDIT TO THE
PROCESS. BUT WE'VE DONE
INDUSTRY DAYS WE MADE A
DECISION ON THIS PROCESS
ALTHOUGH PROCUREMENT IS
AVAILABLE ON THE LEGISLATURE'S
WEBSITE WE ALSO. ANNOUNCES TO
THE TGS WEBSITE SO ANYBODY WHO
IN THEIR BUSINESS PRACTICES
FALL WHICH IS A CALIFORNIA
THINGS WOULD LEARN ABOUT THIS
PROJECT EVEN IF THEY DON'T FIND
OUR WEBSITE. BECAUSE IT'S
ECHOED ON THE TGS WEBSITE. SO I
WOULD CERTAINLY SAY ANY. I
PURSUED ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
KIND OF TALK ABOUT IT
OPPORTUNITIES HERE I'M- NOT
LOOKING TO PUT MY HAND ON THE
SCALE IN TERMS OF HOW WE SORT
THINGS OUT. OPEN TO THE SORT OF
FOLKS WE WOULD WOULD HAVE HERE.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE DEFINITELY
MADE EFFORTS TO KIND OF MAKE
SURE WE OR PUBLICIZING. WHAT'S
GOING ON BUT SO NAY BORE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS VERY APT TO TALK
ABOUT THOSE THAT WOULD BE REACH
OUT. MAKE SURE THEY'VE SEEN IT
MISTER MONEY IN THE MISS
MITCHELL. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I WANT TO THANK MISTER
HURT FOR THE PRESENTATION AND
THE WORK THAT THE MARK OF
LOCUSTS DOING ON THIS. I'M
PARTICULARLY PLEASED TO SEE
THERE'LL BE ALIGNMENT BETWEEN
THE FLOORS. OF THE ANNEX I'VE
BEEN HERE TEN AND A HALF YEARS
I'M STILL TRYING TO FIGURE IT
OUT SO THAT WILL BE A GREAT
ASSET TO THOSE OF US WHO WORK
HERE IN FOR VISITORS. ON A MORE
SERIOUS. ISSUE PRESENTED THE
VISITOR CENTER CONCEPT. IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT WOULD BE
DESIGNED FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT BEFORE GOING
THROUGH. SECURITY CHECK. DOES
THAT CREATE ANY PROBLEMS FOR
THE SECURITY WITHIN THE VISITOR
CENTER. MISTER CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION WE'D HAVE NOT SAT DOWN
WITH SECURITY GONE THROUGH IN
DETAIL SOME OF THE ISSUES WE
HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT THEY HAVE
SOME CONCERNS OVER THAT. THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SIT DOWN AND
LISTEN TO AND THEN TRY TO
ADDRESS WE THINK THAT OF COURSE
SECURITY IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT BECAUSE IT'S A
FACILITY THAT IS. BELOW GRADE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
QUEUING TAKING PLACE ON STAIRS
OR OUT IN THE WEATHER AND SO WE
WANT TO TRY TO FIND A HAPPY
BALANCE SO TO SPEAK BETWEEN THE
TWO. THANKS AND AGAIN I KNOW.
I'M GLAD TO KNOW THAT OUR
SECURITY PEOPLE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH THIS FROM DAY ONE IN
RAISING THEIR QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS AND- THIS MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE FOR OUR OVERVIEW
TODAY BUT JUST THE BROAD
CONCEPT OF. EVACUATIONS IN
SEALING OFF CERTAIN AREAS HAS
THAT BEEN A CONSIDERATION IN
THE DESIGN CONCEPTS WE HAVE.
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT WE
HAVE NOT GOTTEN INTO ANY OF IT
AT THIS POINT. BUT WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT AREAS OF REFUGE
AND- TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE- HAVE SEEMS LIKE IN THE
DESIGN. WOULD CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THAT'S RIGHT
PROTECT LARGE AREAS IF
SOMETHING'S GOING ON IN RIGHT
THERE AND WILL BE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE FIRE MARSHAL
AND OTHER PEOPLE TO KIND OF
HELP WORK THROUGH THAT. GREAT
THANKS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IF I COULD. COMMENT
FIRST AND THANK YOU SENATOR
MINING AS THIRD HERTZBERG TALK
ABOUT THE MANY CHALLENGES OF
THIS DESIGN BOTH THE TEMPORARY
AND THE PERMANENT I'VE RAISING
THE PASS AND DON'T WANT LOS
THAT. THAT IN THIS NEW
CONSTRUCTION IS IT HAS TO DO WE
HAVE TO BE FOR EVER MINDFUL OF
THE SHEER NUMBERS OF THE
GENERAL PUBLIC WERE HERE EVERY
DAY. AND HAVE THE- PHYSICAL
STRUCTURE ABILITY TO EVACUATE
THEM IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY OF ANY TIME. IF YOU
THINK ABOUT ON THE NUMBER OF
DAYS A YEAR THAT FORTY TWO ALL
THREE FORTY TWO OR THREE. ARE
AT CAPACITY COUPLED WITH.
EMPLOYEES AND JUST YOU KNOW THE
NUMBER OF BODIES IN THE SHEER
HALLS I'VE IN THE WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT IN THIS COMMITTEE.
WHETHER OR NOT WE LITERALLY
HAVE ENOUGH EXITS AND STAIR
WELLS TO FOR PEOPLE TO ACCEPT
PROPERLY SO AS YOU'RE DEALING
WITH ALL OF THAT. THE SAFETY
ELEMENT I'M HOPING IS INCLUDED.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
MISTER CHAIRMAN. AGAIN I WOULD
JUST ADD AND I APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSE FROM MISTER HART I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE WHO. YOU KNOW AT
HAVE PARTICIPATED IN AND HAVE
YOU KNOW IMPOSE RESTRICTIONS ON
OURSELVES IN TERMS OF TRAVEL
BAN SIX CETERA THIS WHOLE
NOTION OF CALIFORNIA GROWN BY
CALIFORNIA. AND SO I APPRECIATE
THE EXPECTATIONS THAT THEY HAVE
AN OFFICE IN SACRAMENTO I GET
TAX BASED ON BUSINESS
EFFICIENCY I'M LOOKING AT A
LITTLE BIGGER GRANDER SCALE
AND- THESE ARE PUBLIC DOLLARS
BEING USED TO CONSTRUCT IN THIS
IS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY. FOR US
TO ENGAGE A CALIFORNIA BASED
COMPANY THAT HAS A VARIETY OF
BENEFITS SO I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY. NOT JUST A MATTER HAVE
AN OFFICE IN SACRAMENTO BUT I'M
HOPING THAT WE TRULY DO OUR DUE
DILIGENCE AND CREATED AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR A CALIFORNIA
BASED COMPANY. TO ENGAGE IN THE
PROCUREMENT SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. SIR MORLOCK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I MISTER HART ON
THIS PHOTO I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU
TO GIVE ME THE VISION. FOR THE
VISITOR CENTER BECAUSE- THIS IS
THE ICONIC. VIEW OF THE CAPITOL
AND I'M. YOU KNOW FROM TOWER
BRIDGE TO YOU KNOW EVERYWHERE
THIS IS. THIS IS IT AND I'M
JUST TRYING TO. GRAB YOUR
VISION FOR THE VISITOR CENTER
BEING RIGHT IN THE FRONT. SURE
IT'S UNDERGROUND TOTALLY AGREE
AROUND YES SO IF I'M MAY. IN
THE AREA HERE IS ABOUT THREE
AND A HALF BEFORE WE TALK. SO
THAT WE REPLACE WAS SO SCARED
OUT OVER ON THE SIDE WE ARE
LOCATED IN A SCRATCH. WE HAVE
ABOUT ANY DESIGN SMILED AND
SAID. GLASS ELEVATOR HERE. THE
ELEVATOR HERE FOR PEOPLE WHO
NEED THOSE TIME. SO HE'S WHICH
WOULD TAKE IT DOWN BELOW AND
THERE WOULD BE FOR THE GRASSES
TO ENSURE SKYLIGHT. WHICH IS I
THINK ONE OF THE IMAGES OF YOU.
LOOK EXHAUSTED THE BILL ALSO
BRING IN NATURAL LIGHT. TO THE
LIKE THAT ARE. THE REST OF THE
SPACE WOULD BE JUST AS A
PRESENT. ONE THOUGHT WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IS YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
TERRACE YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT OF
TERRACE HERE WE THOUGHT ABOUT
REINFORCING THAT. AND POSSIBLY
READING IS LIGHT INTO THE LOWER
LEVEL THROUGH A LITTLE STRONGER
TERRACE WITH WHAT HAPPENED AT
THE BASE. WOULD NOT BE ANY
HIGHER THAN THE FLOOR LEVEL.
TAKE YOUR THE SECOND QUESTION.
IN OUR OFFICES SENATOR BATES
AND I WE WERE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS WE HAD A BAXTER
THAT WE COULD EXIT THE BUILDING
FROM AND WE HAD A SEPARATE
ELEVATOR THAT WE CAN ONLY
ACCESS FROM OUR OFFICES SO IF
THERE WAS SOMETHING GOING ON IN
THE LOBBY OR IN THE HALLWAYS
SURE YOU COULD STILL GET OUT
GET TO YOUR CAR. IT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THAT HERE YOU YOU
YOU GET EXPOSED RIGHT THE MANY
YOU'RE OUT IN THE HALLWAY. TV
CRUISER WHO KNOWS WHAT YOU DO
AND YOU JUST HAVE TO DEAL WITH
IT. BUT IT. I'M JUST CURIOUS IN
THE DESIGN WILL THERE BE
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR LEGISLATORS.
JUST TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS FREE
OF. INTRUSION RIGHT WE ARE WE
ARE STUDYING DIFFERENT. DESIGNS
THAT WOULD BE SIMILAR TO WHAT
YOU WOULD SEE IN A COURTHOUSE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE SO THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE A WAY IN IN A WAY
OUT THAT WOULD BE SECURED WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF. IMPACT TO
YOUR ABILITY TO DO THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS BOTH FOR GOOD AND BAD
WHEN YOU HAVE TO WALK OUT INTO
A PUBLIC CORRIDOR IF YOU'RE
LATE FOR A MEETING THAT'S
DIFFICULT SO IN A LOT OF
CAPITAL SO WE HAVE RE DONE WE
USUALLY TRY TO PROVIDE A WAY
OUT THROUGH THE BACK SO THAT
YOU CAN GET TO YOUR NEXT
MEETING. EASILY AND QUICKLY WE
DID THAT BOTH IN UTAH WE'VE
DONE THAT IN WYOMING IN THE
EXTENSION DOWN BELOW AND WE'VE
DONE SOME OF THAT IN THE
MINNESOTA CAPITAL WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT THOSE TYPE OF THINGS
AS WELL AS YOUR OFFICES I THINK
BECAUSE WE ARE LOOKING AT A AN
OFFICE BUILDING. MORE THAN
TRYING TO RESTRUCTURE THE
INTERIOR OF THE CAPITAL WEHAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE KIND
OF A TOOL CORRIDOR SYSTEM SO
THERE WOULD BE A CORRIDOR THAT
WOULD BE DESIGNED FOR THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD ACCOMMODATE
THE LARGE NUMBERS AS YOU HAD A
FEW TO GO WHERE YOU HAD SOME OF
THE HEARINGS YOU'RE HAVING. AS
WELL AS OF EMBERS AN OP YOU TO
MOVE ABOUT AND GET WHERE THEY
THEY NEED TO GO BUT AT THE SAME
TIME GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
IF YOU CHOOSE TO OUT IN IN
INTERACT WITH THE PUBLIC TO
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY. SO WE
WANT TO TRY TO DO. THANK YOU.
YOU CAN THAT IDEA OF THAT. TO
THE COT SHELTER IN SPACE WHICH
IS LESS ABOUT HIS TO THE
MEMBERS IN JUST A PRACTICAL
UPDATE IN FACILITIES FOR SORT
OF THE ERROR WE FIND OURSELVES
IN BECAUSE I THINK THOSE SORTS
OF SPACES WHILE THEY DO SPEED
YOU ABOUT YOUR WORK. AND THE
GOD'S HONEST TRUTH IS A
LAWMAKER. YOUR BASIC LIFE IS TO
DEPLOY YOUR SELF THE SPAN OF
HOURS YOU HAVE IN THE BUILDING
HAS EFFECTIVELY YOU CAN WHEN
YOU'RE PUBLIC BUSINESS. SO THIS
WHOLE BILL IS ABOUT DEPLOYMENT
OF SELF ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
LAWMAKERS AND THIS WAS A
QUARTER TO SUPPORT THAT BUT
THERE IS A SHELTER SPACE.
CONRAD COULD YOU SORT OF
CONNECTED TO CORRECT WE HAVE.
YES AND IF IT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
AS YOU SAW ON THE DIAGRAM THE
PARKING STRUCTURE IS NOT
UNDERNEATH THE- NEW ANNEX. THE
NEW ACT WILL HAVE A BASEMENT
AND YOU'LL BE ABLE TO GO OUT
THERE AND THERE WILL BE.
CONNECTING ELEMENTS THAT'LL
CONNECT YOU FROM THE ANNEX
BUILDING THE NEW ANNEX BUILDING
TO THE NEW PARKING STRUCTURE.
AND WE HAVE LOOKED AT MAKING
THOSE POSSIBLY AN AREA WHERE IF
THERE'S AN EMERGENCY YOU CAN
CHILDREN PLACE. OR IF THERE IS
A THREAT THAT YOU CAN YOU CAN
GO THERE WE THINK THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT ASPECT SO THAT YOU
CAN BE REMOVED FROM THAT
THREATEN BE SAFE IF THERE IS
SOMETHING. BUT YET STILL BE
ABLE TO COME BACK ONCE THE
BUILDING HAS BEEN CLEARED AND
CONTINUE WITH THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS. THANK YOU RETIREMENT
MS COMMODO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
PRESENTATION I'M ACTUALLY
HAVING FLASHBACKS OF MY TIME AT
THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND OVERSEEING
THE CONSTRUCTION BOND THAT WE
HAD THERE FAR SMALLER NUMBERS
VERY SIMILAR CONVERSATIONS I
WROTE SOME THINGS DOWN AND
BECAUSE I STEPPED IN LATE MAYBE
THERE WERE SOME THINGS THAT YOU
HAD PRESENTED AND SORT OF
ANSWER FOR ME SO IF THAT'S THE
CASE I WANT TO APOLOGIZE IN
ADVANCE. BUT I WAS CURIOUS
ABOUT THE QUESTION RAISED BY
SENATOR MITCHELL ABOUT YOU KNOW
SUBS PRIMES APPRENTICESHIP
OPPORTUNITIES I KNOW WHEN WE
RALLY CCD AND WE WERE WORKING
WITH PRIME IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ALSO ASKED AS YOU KNOW
WHAT KIND OF APPRENTICE
OPPORTUNITIES WE'RE GOING TO BE
PUT IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE CREATING A PIPELINE
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
VOCATIONAL TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES EXPANDING ON THAT
IS THE CONVERSATION AROUND
LOCAL HIRE. AND EVEN THOUGH
THIS IS CONSTRUCTION THAT'S
HAPPENING IN SACRAMENTO IT IS A
STATE BUILDING AND SO HOW WE
WOULD BE DEFINING LOCAL HIGHER
IN THIS INSTANCE ALSO HAD A
QUESTION KIND OF ABOUT. THE
FINANCING OF THIS I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S THE SAME BUT WHEN I WAS
THAT THE DISTRICT WE ALSO HAD
BOND ISSUANCE FIRMS THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR. THE SELLING OF
THE BOND SO THAT WE COULD
FINANCE THE CONSTRUCTION AND
DIDN'T KNOW IF YOU COULD SHARE
ANY HIGHLIGHTS ON THAT. AND
ONCE AGAIN YOU KNOW THERE WAS A
PROCUREMENT PROCESS A BIDDING
PROCESS TO FIND THOSE FIRMS AND
HOW WE ARE WORKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S DIVERSEREPRESENTATION. IN IN THAT AREA
AS WELL. IF YOU COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR
EXPECTATION AROUND CHANGE
ORDERS I SEE THAT THE NUMBER IS
QUITE HIGH EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND SO I ALSO
SEE THAT THERE'S CONTINGENCIES.
WE ARE. IN THE THROES OF
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS AROUND
TRADE AND TERRORISTS AND SO
JUST WANT TO GET A SENSE OF
WHAT OUR EXPECTATIONS ARE ABOUT
THE STAYING ON BUDGET OR BELOW
BUDGET. YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
REALITIES OF THE DAY THIS IS A
HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY AND JUST
WANT TO HAVE A REALISTIC
UNDERSTANDING OF IF WE WOULD BE
COMING BACK TO THE TABLE. WITH
BUDGETING. AS IT RELATES TO
CONSTRUCTION ALSO THINKING
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
RECYCLING REUSING MATERIALS YOU
KNOW AND IF THAT'S A
CONVERSATION AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SUSTAINABLE CONSTRUCTION.
AS YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
VISITORS CENTER I ALSO BEGIN TO
THINK ABOUT EXCAVATION YOU KNOW
AND I HAVE A SCENARIO WHERE WE
WERE LOOKING TO UPGRADE ONE OF
OUR COLLEGES AND. I'M THE NOSE
TO EVERYONE IT WAS ALMOST LIKE
THERE WAS A- OIL REFINERY
UNDERNEATH ONE OF THE BUILDINGS
AND SO THE COST TO ACTUALLY
CLEAN ALL OF THEN OUT THROUGH
THE EXCAVATION WAS ALMOST THE
SAME AS THE COST TO. BUILD THE
NEW FACILITY AND SO IF THERE
ANY SORT OF PLAN PRELIMINARY
DATA THAT YOU HAVE ABOUT WHAT.
UNEXPECTED THINGS THAT WILL NOW
BE EXPECTED THAT YEAR. THAT
WILL BE UNDERNEATH ALL OF THIS
AS WE'RE DOING THAT THAT WOULD
BE CURIOUS TO ME TO KNOW
BECAUSE IT'S THOSE THINGS THAT
END UP RAISING THE COST SO I
KNOW THAT THOSE ARE A WHOLE LOT
OF QUESTIONS AND I'M SORRY FOR
MY PTSD BUT- SO THEY'RE VERY
IMPORTANT. THANK. HE WANTED TO
THE PRINCE. OKAY SO I CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTION WITH WITH
RESPECT APPRENTICESHIPS UNDER
THE MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
THAT I TALK ABOUT MY
PRESENTATION ONE OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
IS TO WORK OUT THE PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS AND COMMUNITY
WORKFORCE AGREEMENTS AND IN OUR
PRELIMINARY DISCUSSIONS IT'S
CLEAR TO ME AND I THINK THEY
WOULD REITERATE THAT
APPRENTICESHIPS ARE A BIG PART.
OF THOSE AGREEMENTS INTO SURE
THAT THAT'S PART OF THE PROCESS.
IN IT IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
ALWAYS ENCOURAGE. THE
CONTRACTORS THAT WE WORK WITH
TO. GO OUT AND SEEK A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT SUB CONTRACTORS.
TO PROPOSE ON THESE PROJECTS IN
IN AND THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO
WORK THROUGH THAT THEY'LL
PROVIDE INDUSTRY DAYS AND OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS TO BRING PEOPLE
TO THAT TO CREATE CREATE
GENERATE INTEREST. IN THOSE
THINGS SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT AND TRY TO. BRING ALL
THE DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT WE
CAN TO THE TABLE SO THAT WE CAN
UTILIZE. THOSE INDIVIDUALS. AS
FAR AS BONDS AGO I'M NOT REALLY
INVOLVED WITH THE BOND SIDE OF
THINGS I THINK HAT. FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS WE SHOULD PROBABLY
TALK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND HOW THOSE ARE. ARE
BEING HANDLED. WITH REGARD TO
CHANGE ORDERS I CAN EITHER WILL
BE CHANGE ORDERS NO SET OF
DRAWINGS BY AN ARCHITECT IS
PERFECT. WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THOSE INSURERS WILL PROBABLY BE
IN THE 567% RANGE WHICH IS
PRETTY STANDARD IN THE INDUSTRY
WE WILL WORK WITH THOSE
ARCHITECTS AND ENGINEERS TO TRY
TO GET THOSE DOWN AS LOW AS
POSSIBLE AND I THINK ONE OF THE
KEYS TO THAT IS UTILIZING
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT RISK AS
WELL AS A DESIGN BUILD
PROCUREMENT METHOD. I THINK
THAT WAY WERE ABLE TO
ANTICIPATE THROUGH A VARIETY OF
CONSTRUCTION DOCUMENT REVIEWS
AND CONSTRUCT ABILITY REVIEWS
BY THE CONTRACTOR TO PROVIDE
THE ARCHITECT WITH INFORMATION
SO THAT THEY CAN IMPROVE THE
DRYING BEFORE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
FINISHED TOO OFTEN THOSE
DRAWINGS COME OUT WITH ERRORS
OMISSIONS OR THINGS THAT ARE
NOT COMPLETE LET'S JUST SAY.
AND BY HAVING A GOOD CONSTRUED
ABILITY REVIEW BY A
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER OR
SOMEBODY WHO IS THEY'RE GOING
TO BUILD THE BUILDING AND WHO'S
GOING TO GIVE US WHAT'S CALLED
A GUARANTEED MAXIMUM PRICE TO
THE BUILDING BUT WE ARE ABLE TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF CHANGE
ORDERS SO WE'VE SEEN I'M PROUD
THAT WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN.
FROM UTAH TO MINNESOTA MEANING.
WE'VE BEEN. LARGE COMPLICATED
OBJECTS ON BUDGET BELOW BUDGET
AND SO I FEEL I FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH THE BUDGET
NUMBER IN THE CONTINGENCIES
THAT WE'VE PUT TOGETHER NOW AS
WE GO THROUGH AND WE LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE PROJECT AND WE START
TO SEE DESIGNS COME ABOUT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO BUDGETING
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
ESTIMATING A SOME OF THAT
CONTINGENCY THAT IS CURRENTLY
THERE WILL MOVE INTO OTHER
PORTIONS OF THE PROJECT WE WILL
ALWAYS CARRY A CONTINGENCY
HOWEVER TO ACCOMMODATE AND MAKE
SURE WE CAN HANDLE. THE CHANGE
ORDERS UP WILL BE A ANTICIPATED.
AND THEN IT FAR AS THE
MATERIALS AND EXCAVATION WE
HAVE ALREADY STARTED. A
DIALOGUE WITH SOME OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES THAT
WERE FAMILIAR IN THIS AREA. THE
SEQUEL. REPORT HAS IDENTIFIED
THOSE WE BEGUN CONVERSATIONS
WITH ASSEMBLYMAN ROMMEL'S. WITH
REGARDS TO HOW WE WANT TO
PROCEED WE'RE LOOKING AT A
VARIETY OF WAYS OF. TRYING TO
IDENTIFY IF THERE ARE ANY
REMAINS FROM BOTH EXCAVATION AS
WELL AS CADAVER DOGS. WE ARE
ALSO PUTTING IN PLACE PROTOCOL
AND PROCEDURES TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THAT AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT WE HAVE JUST COMPLETED A
EARLY PRELIMINARY ENVIRONMENTAL
OR NOT. THE GEO TECHNICAL
REPORT TO WHERE WE START TO GET
AN UNDERSTANDING WHAT IS BELOW
THE GROUND. AND GIVING US AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
STRADDLE US LIKE AS WE- MOVE
FORWARD. SO I THINK THOSE WERE
YOUR- ALL THE LOCAL HIGHER. I
AM I HAVE TO GO LOOK INTO THAT
A LITTLE BIT MORE TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE OPPORTUNITY
IS THERE. AND HOW TO DEFINE
THAT IS YOUR QUESTION AND WE
WILL DO THAT AND- TRY TO GET
INFORMATION BACK TO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS SENATOR
NIELSEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND. VERY EXCITING AND
HISTORIC TIME AND I'VE LIKE TO
KIND OF HEARKEN TO THE PAST
JUST BET. AS WE PROCEED TO THE
FUTURE. IT WAS INVASION ONE THE
OLD SIDE HERE THE ICONIC SIDE
WAS DEEMED TO BE NON BUT NOT
SAFE FOR. EARTHQUAKES. A LOT OF
DISCUSSION OCCURRED AND I WAS
NOT HERE THEN. BUT I WOULD
PROBABLY DO WHAT WENT ON. AND
THE DESIGN OF THE TWO TWIN
TOWERS WAS BECOMING A PREFERRED
OPTION FOR THE NEW CAPITAL. AND
THE DESTRUCTION OF THIS ICONIC
SIDE. I WOULD ARGUE THAT LIES
REMINDS PREVAILED. AND THE
RESTORATION OF KURT. IT WAS
RATHER AMAZING THAT. ARTISANS
AND WORKMEN COULD IN WOMEN
COULD BE FOUND THAT COULD
EMULATE THE WORK OF THAT HERE.
IT HAPPENED WONDERFUL. THAT WAS
RESTORED. AND IT WAS DONE IN A
MANNER THAT WAS COMPLIMENTARY
TO THE NINETEEN FIFTIES.
ADDITION TO THE CAPITAL. DIDN'T
DETRACT FROM THE DID VIRTUALLY
I WOULD SAY. ADDED TO IT. BUT
AS THIS IS PROGRESS TO DO
DECADES THERE HAS BEEN A
HEARKENING TO PRESERVE THAT
ICONIC INTEGRITY. OF THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE AS ITS
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE CAPITAL.
SOME MODIFICATIONS WERE MADE IN
THE GOLDEN DOME BECAME LESS
GOLDEN THAT IT HAD BEEN BEFORE
BUT- IT WAS LARGELY PRESERVED.
AND IT IS MY HOPE AND I KNOW
THAT SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE.
ARE VERY MUCH DEBT DEVOTED TO
HISTORY. UNDER HERTZBERG CENTER
MORE LIKE AN OBVIOUS YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN I KNOW IS. THAT WE ASK
BROUGH PROCEED THAT WE'RE
CAREFUL ABOUT THAT. PRESERVER
PRESERVATION OF THAT ICONIC
INTEGRITY THAT WE HAVE ENJOYED
HERE. IT ACTUALLY CONTINUED
EVEN TO THE OPENING OF THAT.
GRAND CAPITAL WHEN THE
RESTORATION WAS COMPLETED AND
THERE WAS A DINNER. IN THE
ROTUNDA FOR ALL THE LEGISLATORS.
WHAT WAS SERVED WAS PERIOD FOOD.
THE POWER FAMILY OF THE NUT
TREE FAME ACTUALLY EMULATED THE
KINDS OF MEALS. ONE WOULD HAVE
IN THOSE YEARS NO I'M NOT
TRYING TO GET TO THAT FIND
NIGHT OF DEGREE BUT I'M SAYING
THAT THERE WAS CERTAINLY AT AND
IT HERE IT'S- TO HISTORY. AND I
WOULD ENCOURAE US AS WE
PROCEED HERE BEING STEWARDS OF
THE FUTURE. TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT SAYS VERY CAREFULLY
PRESERVED WHAT I'VE SEEN OF
YOUR EFFORTS SO FAR THOSE WHO
HAVE PRECEDED YOU AND US HERE
DEVELOPING THIS PROJECT I THINK
THAT YOU'RE- YOU'RE WELL ON
YOUR WAY TO MAINTAINING THAT
INTEGRITY. BUT AS MY SMALL PART
OF THIS OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS I'M GOING TO CERTAINLY BE
AWARE AND WARY OF ENSURING THAT
INTEGRITY. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE WE HAVE
BEEN JOINED BY THE SECTOR THE
SENATE ERICA CONTRAIRE US WHO
WITH HER COUNTERPART EVER
GRAVER MY HOUSES OKAY HELPING
SUPPORT THIS ENTERPRISE SO. AN
HONOR TO HAVE YOU HERE. MS CAN
FIRST THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WITHOUT I WANT TO SAY THIS IS
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING. AND
AS DESCRIBED WE HAVE BEEN JUST.
POUNDING AWAY ON THIS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE ESTABLISHED
A LEADERSHIP STRUCTURE WORK
WITH THE. BROWN A NEW SUPER
MINISTRATION WERE MEETING
REGULARLY THE POS DOCUMENT THIS
DOCTOR WHICH STRUCTURES THE
SCHEDULE IN THE BUDGET AND THE
DELIVERY METHOD IS COMING
TOGETHER ACCORDING TO A PLAN.
WE'RE PROCEEDING TO PUT THAT IN
PLACE I WOULD EXPECT THAT AT
OUR NEXT EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE
MEETING. THE POS BASIC
STRUCTURE WILL BE APPROVED BY
THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE. AND SO
I ANTICIPATE THAT WILL ACTUALLY
SEEK TO HAVE A BRIEF JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE MEETING BEFORE
WE ADJOURN FOR THE FALL. WHERE
WE AS A JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
SORT OF GIVE A THUMBS UP TO THE
PLAN IS IT HAS BEEN DEVELOPED
SWIM OUT THEY DIDN'T TAKE THE
NEXT STEP WORK AT THE PUBLIC
WORKS FOR THE PARK FINANCE. I
DO WANT TO SAY THAT SENATOR
NIELSEN HAS ALLUDED THE
RESTORATION OF THAT BUILDING.
WHICH WAS DONE AND FULLY
FUNDED. BY GOVERNOR BRAND AT
THE OUTSET FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS INTO THE LESSER COUNTS
FOR THAT PROJECT. AND THESE
STAIRS STRIPPER TERREL THE
DIANNE BOARD ONE SUBSCRIBER
SIMILARLY CONTEMPLATES THAT
UPON THE COMPLETION OF THE
PURSUANT TO THEM YOU OF
PURSUANT TO LESSEN AGREEMENT
ONCE WE AGREE ON THINGS WE SEND
IT OVER THE PUBLIC WORKS FOR
WERE UPON ITS APPROVAL FUNDING
WOULD MOVE OVER. AND THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF THE BOND FUNDING WAS
INDEED INTENDED TO BE BACK UP
PLAN. THE FACT IS WHATEVER
PRICE TAG ASSOCIATE THIS
PROJECT MAY BE IT WILL BE
CHEAPER IF WE'RE NOT PAYING
INTEREST ON THE FUNDS TO THE
BONTA MAC. AND SO I A I THINK
THE GOVERNOR BROWN GAVE GREAT
LEADERSHIP TO AGREE TO A METHOD
THAT WE COULD SET UP A PLAN.
PUT IN PLACE AND THEN HAVE THAT
FUNDING PROVIDED AND IT'S BEEN
THE WORK OF. QUITE A BIT OF
TIME OUR SENIOR STAFF WORK WITH
OTHERS IN STATE GOVERNMENT. ANY
FUNDS ALLOCATE THIS PROGRAM BY
THIS PROCESS WILL BE EARNING
INTEREST. SO WE WILL HAVE
INTEREST IT WILL BE A PART OF
THAT AND IT SAT IN NUMBERS TO
THE- TO THE SOUNDNESS OF THE
PROJECT. SO WITH THAT. I THINK
THE- OFFICIAL GIVEN TAKE A BACK
AND FORTH WE DO HAVE AN OPTION
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE WE SHOULD MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT I WOULD INVITE
YOU FORWARD. AT THIS TIME TO
SIT BENEATH THE SCREEN. AND. I
WILL I KNOW WE HAVE THE C. H.
P. IN THE ROOM THEREFORE
CLOSELY FOLLOWING THE SECURITY
CONVERSATION AND WITH OUR
SERGEANTS THAT'S A KEY ROLE
BECAUSE OF WE ARE MAKING LATE
CHOICES ON SECURITY THOSE WILL
BE VERY EXPENSIVE TO GET TO THE
CHANGE ORDER ISSUE BUT THEY
HAVE BEEN UNCONSCIOUS WITH US
FOR MORE THAN TWO YEARS AND I
THINK THEY HAVE BEEN A PART OF
TRYING TO KEEP THE COSTS ON
TRACK ALL OF OURS. SERGEANTS.
SO THEN WITH THAT HAVING NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT I THINK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
TO THIS MATTER AND THIS. FIFTY
MEETING OF THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE CAP LAST
PROJECT IS HEREBY JR